and we are back with another i'm not gm
speed chess championship match amman
i'm so glad to have you back today with
what's the first
quarterfinal matchup of this year's
edition
yeah the uh the tournaments are you know
very exciting and
i am not a gm i always get this feeling
like i can't wait to come back
robert you know i miss a day because the
match happens really early
and it's always nice to be back for the
commentary of the next match
for sure and we have a fun one in store
for everyone today because it's lawrence
trent
against roberto molina and you know we
need to make some predictions among
who are you going with yeah roberto
molino is actually one of the matches
that i didn't
commentate the first round of i've
commentated a lot of these matches but
that's one other one i didn't
didn't see so i think he was playing
alexia santoramo
um he ended up winning the match pretty
convincingly
which is what we might expect but he's
actually a player that i've
only really known online so i played him
a lot online in like bullet chess
especially
and the most that i know about him he's
a very very tricky bullet player a very
strong bullet player him and i played a
lot of matches
so i only really know about his bullet
chest and lawrence i mean i don't think
we really got to see him flex his
muscles i mean at the end of the day
robert
he only played danny ranch
i won't go so far as to agree with you
there but danny was not in his best
shape but lawrence
was extremely impressive but we know
that he's tweeted about wanting to
become a grandmaster he says
it's now's the time i'm going to put my
mind to it so if he is taking that
task seriously and he's preparing that
means this could be his last time
playing the i'm not gm speeches
championship
yeah that's right no i'm very excited to
see
lawrence uh take something like the
grand master title seriously i actually
saw a tweet from attila terzo
another uh streamer who said he was
going for the gm title so
i love to see this uh dedication from
some of the players
to the grand master title and roberto
molina is another guy
you know with his style he could
definitely go for the grand master title
pretty soon as well
for sure and let's remind everybody of
what we're here for what the format is
like
we will have 75 minutes of five minute
plus one second increment blitz
followed by 45 minutes of the three plus
one and then ultimately we get to the
bullet chest 25 minutes of that
and as is always the case only one
winner
will be crowned today they will move on
to the semifinals but i'm on the prize
fund getting bigger
so for those who are still in the
competition
and they can keep on going they'll be
enjoying this final stretch here
yeah this is a nice nice prize fun for
the players and
it then the thing that i like about it
is that it keeps the match
interesting the whole way you know if
the match finishes 10 9
where the match finishes you know 20 to
zero that's a much different payout
for the players so i like the format the
way that the prizes are
distributed that it keeps the match
exciting for us
even if we already know who's gonna uh
you know win the match
for sure and let's uh remind everybody
how we got here you mentioned that
roberto he did beat alessia that was in
point odds match he was very impressive
to storm back
and lawrence trent probably had the
single most impressive first round
because
he at least on paper by seating he was
the underdog
but he didn't look any bit that part he
was there to shine against danny wrench
and
i think when he plays his quote-unquote
nemesis he
brings the best out of him so he wants
to play the greg shahadis of the world
and that's why he's playing so well as
he sees greg on the other side of the
bracket
he wants them to meet in the final yeah
and you bring up such an interesting
point and i think
i think it plays exactly into the
character of lawrence trent
i'm actually wondering to your point
whether he views
his opponent today in that light and i
don't think he does
i don't think that he really knows that
much about his opponent you know he
he can drum up the hype in his usual way
with a few tweets and stuff like that
but
when he's playing danny ranch where he's
playing greg shahadi john bartholomew
you know you really as you said it
brings the best out of him and
he he thrives in that environment so i
feel like today
with with an opponent from brazil that
he might know a bit less about and
he's definitely a very strong solid
player in his own right
that uh this could be a very tough match
just stylistically for
for lawrence yeah i think that something
can be misleading
it's that with an odds match as roberto
played in the first round
you're going to play totally different
openings right if you need to win to
catch up
you will play sharper chess you will do
different things than if you're starting
zero zero or two to two right so that's
happens in every single sport
when you're back's against the wall you
need to play something for
win you need to take risks and so i'm
going to be curious
how roberto starts this match and for
lawrence how he manages his clock
because sometimes he goes
to think tank and that's when it spells
trouble for many of these players
yeah no that's a that's a great point as
well and of course full
full credit to lawrence because people
like to sell danny short you know
myself included but at the end of the
day danny's an incredibly strong player
especially when he shows up
um and and lawrence was able to beat him
by
a pretty convincing margin so that that
match
really says to me that lawrence can can
you know win this whole thing like he's
capable of that
um this event so uh florence shows up
the same way he did against danny has
those tricky openings
what we noticed from his style in that
last match is that he had
opening systems that he really he really
knew and he was willing to play over and
over
and danny wasn't able to solve them
quickly and lawrence was getting way up
on the clock and using that
to his advantage as we see the
five-minute portion uh just getting
underway
and we spoke to kriker mkhitaryan the
beloved
uh head of portuguese content for
chess.com a great streamer in his own
right and compatriot of roberto molina
he says that roberto goes to his
caracons his tried and true opening and
he says i'm going to stop playing it at
some point and he never does but we have
a very strange start to this with the b2
pawn is that poison iman or is roberto
going to get away with it
um well i think that the answer can be
yes and yes
to that to that series of questions uh i
think it
is probably one of those poison pawns
where you can see the evaluation bar
on the left-hand side hovering around
the the you know the center of the board
which is more around equal territory and
to beat down upon
and still have a position that is around
equal usually indicates that there's
pretty good compensation
so i think it is sort of a poison pond
variation
lawrence is already starting with the
h-pawn you know knight g to e2
and he's just got easy king-side
pressure when as soon as this knight
develops and black castles
you're going to see that bishop come to
h6 for for lawrence and i think this is
sort of
his styles more of a more of a tricky
sort of blitz type of opening to be down
upon already
i agree and the plans for white actually
are pretty easy e5 now actually comes
with tempo i wasn't suggested
even if the knight went to e7 now you
can go for g4 eventually knight f4 maybe
a sacrifice on g6
and even if some of it is speculative in
blitz chess these kind of sacrifices
almost always work so
i would be looking at that kind of quick
attack and there we see
lawrence goes right forward and look at
how much more development he has he's
all four minor pieces out there
look at black's queen side completely
stuck useless to fend off the attack
that's about to happen and the sacrifice
in the g6 square so knight of fate is a
good move
yeah and and the knight going to f6
means that uh the
maybe the more natural development of
like 97 knight d7
is impossible so what you're going to
see here is you're going to see some of
the pieces sort of bumping into each
other
the bishop on g7 is not that great
hitting these pawns
black can't even challenge the center
with c5 because
knight b5 knight d6 is always killer so
he sort of has to play like
a6 to prepare c5 but at the same time
this bishop needs to get out so you got
to go b6 to get the bishop out there's
just
so many different plans that seem to
overlap and what i'm seeing from the
position right now is that
black species they don't feel like they
can develop comfortably here
and lawrence has you know one plan and
he's just executing it
although knight to e2 now you can't play
c5 because
what you were just saying was absolutely
correct that c5 you want to play but
can't if the knight jumps into b5
and into d6 but that knight went to e2
so now feels like the time
to go c5 and i understand that there
will be risk the b5 score still wipes
for the taking with a
perhaps a bishop b5 check but i need to
get active i need to free the c6 square
for my knight
i need to make sure i can fully develop
otherwise i'm sitting and doing nothing
yep and a6 blade which i think has to do
with
exactly that square and probably the c5
move incoming
but i just don't know if you have time
for for moves like this and
c4 i i kind of like as a as a reply he's
going to take it and
maybe he's going to try to establish a
knight on d5 but hang on that e4 square
robert just became available after d
takes c4
and i think that roberto molina might
regret that
he's definitely going gonna regret it
because his bishop on g7 isn't actually
doing much of anything that's like his
one developed piece everything else all
of his miners and his rooks on the
first rank the eighth rank in this case
so he brings the knight to d7 i'm
already looking what was that knight
doing
covering the g6 pawn can i get away with
bishop takes e6 knight takes g6
a sacrifice of a piece for two pawns but
you also get that rook in the corner
no he plays well i was gonna say more
tamely but that's a king on g3 so
i don't know if that's very team chess i
don't
know what uh he might be thinking like
whether he just wants to bring his king
to like
the h file like thinking that it's more
castled or more safe over there
i have to say i don't really get this
move because hey the king is so safe on
f2
g4 is one of the main ideas it looks
like he might go for
and this kind of stops like both of them
it's
you know less safe on g3 more
susceptible to checks
i have to say i just don't really don't
really get that move it doesn't look
terrible but it looks unnecessary
right it also makes it harder to attack
because if you sacrifice a piece
you're opening up the board and your
king is on g3 so
right now knight is coming to d6 that's
a problem i believe that
roberto he has to just say doesn't look
great but maybe i should just castle
king side i
i think i'm gonna get attacked and
probably check me regardless of what i
do so i
he does it but i wouldn't be happy about
it yeah this this castling i i think i
feel a little bit better doing this now
that the king is here
though uh in all honesty if that king
was there i'd be like okay g4 is coming
and you know bad things are happening to
good people um
g5 great move right instead of just
moving the knight bishop g5 hits the
queen establishes
the f6 square as the knights for the
taking
and yeah knight f6 check this could be a
very quick game
at this point yeah he's he's going to
take with the bishop do you think he's
going to take that or just go king hit
man if this king was on f2 this would
be game over that's true right because
there are some tactics revolving around
the fact that e5 pawn is pinned well not
as much anymore but there could be one
you play bishop h6 i could take your
knight on f6
and you can't take me back so rook c1
what a calm move
and threads to win a pawn on d5 so
developing bishop e6 i don't
love rook c1 it feels like it's giving
black time but i see the eval bar
is through the roof yeah i i would
move the king and you know f4 g4 or
maybe both of them
those those are the moves i want to do
basically if you play g4 and they take
it
h5 will win the game immediately i think
getting that rook involved is checkmate
for sure
although because it says like plus nine
or whatever i can't really see it's all
the way up knight takes h5 and bishop f6
probably just leaves the checkmate
knight h5 bishop f6 damn no not even h6
not anymore because the knight came d7
this is why i didn't like rook c1
it wasn't because i spotted the tactic
right away it's because it took time
and it has a purpose to it but now if
i'm roberto
i'm trying to strike back can i play a
c5 move probably not i don't think i
have time to do so
but that's the kind of thing that black
needs maybe a queen b6 or
you get the point i need to strike back
and now the e5 pawn is hanging
in addition to d4 pawn being under
attack definitely
i love queen f4 um
first glance type of move sort of covers
both of those pawns at the same time
now the king on g3 makes a lot of sense
by the way so it's not like we can play
it right away but
i like queen f4 king g3 if necessary and
and sort of just continue
our plan over here uh it goes queen e3
similar idea i feel like f4 was
a little closer to the action agreed
though with gtx h5
the next move to be played it feels like
black's king is
going to be harassed no matter what so
this looks like a checkmate on the
horizon
and i have to say lawrence has played
this game very well
and roberto probably should not go back
to this opening as you said from the
get-go
this is lawrence's style and what we
spoke about with uh krikor
uh mkhitaryan he was saying that roberto
likes to trade pieces
he is of the schooling of anderson the
like of let's trade pieces get to the
end game and i'll play you
this is anything but that anything about
that now if you're trading pieces
you're only helping yourself getting get
mated here so he's probably not happy
with his prospects queen e3
nice move let's take stock of the time
as well you know a minute
ticking down for roberto and not only
does he have the tougher position but
you know head in his hands right now
on cam he he knows that
this is just hopeless hopeless defensive
task
and i didn't even notice this but look
at the rating differential between these
two roberto's rating is 27.60
lawrence is 25.70 in blitz that's like
200 rating points
and yet in game one lauren says you
think i care about that number
i'm on that path i'm trying to make
progress let me go and just
checkmate your king so rookie played do
not take that rook that's funny right
normally you just
take a rook with your knight that sounds
like a good trade but just go for the
checkmate don't waste your time
yeah no he he knows okay so bishop takes
f6 he wants i i think he wants uh or
roberto rather wants like bishop takes
f6
some sort of queen h6 pawn takes
blundering you know queen d4 it takes f6
but
what he's going to do is he's going to
take first with the pawn on f6 to
threaten queen h6 made in two
um must be king g8 to keep playing this
game oh
just h takes g6 and h5 i mean all the
pawns are coming
[Laughter]
this doesn't look very pleasant the
nasty thing is after h5 you're
threatening like
almost queen h6 like you could really
hurt the guy bishop g6 is a nice touch
from uh
from lawrence as well there and and
roberto's gonna resign what a resounding
first game
there from from lawrence robert that was
super impressive
he just made a fantastic player look
like he's you know
400 ready points lower and that goes to
show that when lawrence is playing his
best and stylistically
when he gets that kind of position he
can really thrive but roberto now with
the white pieces
let's see if he can even the score up
we're getting a king's indian defense
this is standard stuff here and i get
the feeling that we're not going to see
the sharp lines where
white plays d5 black plays you know the
pawn to f5
and then we have essentially white
pushing on the queen side black trying
to check me on the king side
because i feel like roberto does not
want that kind of tactical battle
exactly um so we'll see what he goes for
because
to me lawrence is not going to be saying
no to that
so we've got one player who's going to
agree to play that sort of style
um it just depends how roberto wants to
go and
h5 played already i have to say that
seems like a bit of an
odd move to me but i'm sure it's not uh
not completely ludicrous
yeah the problem with playing h5 is it
makes some of your other plans more
difficult but
in the style of the king's indian if i
could just start marching my pawns at
the board
then i can get an attack but the g5
squares whites for the taking
so you have to be careful before you
push up onto h4 white will just put the
bishop one g5 to attack that pawn so
i do prefer white's position them on
generally speaking in these kind of
kings indians that are
closed so i feel like roberto has
exactly what he wants
definitely rook b1 looking for b4 taking
the c5 square and basically saying that
knight on a6 not participating at all
in the game and as you mentioned each
for bishop g5
is is always uh always a nice way to
react um
if bishop g5 doesn't happen i mean you
know black's always looking for ideas
like knight h7
try to play f5 or maybe h4 knight h5
um if bishop g5 isn't played to maybe
jump in
to the f4 square but i get the feeling
lawrence is kind of on both sides here
like
he started playing h5 then he's played
c6 i don't really know which side of the
board he's trying to play on
and that can cause confusion for roberto
and you're right that sometimes in order
to get the best attack possible
you need to threaten things on the other
side of the board from where you're
attacking but
this can't be good for black look at
this pawn on d6
permanent weakness the bishop on e2 is
now a very strong piece whereas before
it was behind that c4 pawn
and now the c4 square is free so knight
c4 going right after the d6 square
this looks very bad for black yeah
knight c4
um also means that b4 can happen next
um kicking that knight out right now it
looks like
maybe still playable but i wouldn't go
for it because the knight on c3 is loose
so b4 is a little a little risky but
knight c4
hitting the d6 pawn with the knight and
especially after his move queen
to f2 he's looking at ideas like knight
c4 and then there's like knight takes e5
knight takes d6 moves to undermine that
knight on c5
yes and what roberto did makes sense he
didn't put the knight c4 yet but he put
his work on c1 he's just
using the queen side and this is how the
king's inning goes
except for the fact that black's attack
never got started right normally
your pawn's already on f5 and you're
going for something on the queen side
here white is just first knight c4 now
knight to b6
coming next this looks so good for
roberto it really does um sometimes in
these positions you have to
um you know give thought to move b5
which actually keeps your bishop trapped
behind enemy lines
sometimes that bishop just simply
doesn't get out again so
b5 something to consider you mentioned
knight b6 makes a ton of sense
um yeah at this point he's just taking
over the c file and we talked about
trading those pieces
in game one this looks like a lot more
in that style
black is not getting a dangerous attack
when you know half his attackers just
got traded off the board
that's right and this bishop on g7
remains a permanent problem so don't be
surprised when lawrence tries bishop f6
bishop g5
because this is the downside of the
king's inu when you upon
as they say bad bishops they're good
pawns your e5 pawn is great but your
bishop one g7 is not doing very well so
i
like white's position but you do need to
be careful for example for the queen b5
trying to go all in on the queen side if
black can quickly muster some counter
play on the king side that could spell
some trouble and i i think bishop f6
bishop g5 it's a little slow
but if you can accomplish that the dark
squares around the white king
could be in danger yeah and it's so easy
to
you know go queen b5 and after they take
on e4
go queen h4 knight f6 knight g4 e4 pawn
is hanging it's really easy for the
counter play
to arrive so so quick so he's actually
taken on f5
probably because he saw pawn takes e4
and some of those moves i was talking
about and it's not so clear how to
defend that e pawn when it's all alone
there
that's right and this may look bad for
white and since the d5 pawn is isolated
but you already have all the defenders
you need for that pawn
and e4 is a good move because that
bishop on g7 i was
laughing at it now it looks great that's
not a long diagonal
and as you said knight f6 knight g4
queen h4
all these moves might happen so i would
start with knight f6 and i think that
induces
h3 from white but that hurts the king
side
yep yeah we might see like an h4 after
that
uh as white the the thing you like maybe
about knight f6
is that it stops queen h4 so then it
makes a move like queen c7
you know 10 times more attractive that
you you almost forced that that queen
trade or
you'd like to think and then you're also
attacking these pawns on the queen side
i think if the queen's disappeared here
then uh roberto molina can execute his
plan of like brooks c7
you know get this pawn and try to
promote that guy there's just
one issue at the current moment that if
knight f6 happens and queen c7 i will
trade queens and play knight g4 your
knight on b6
is on the same diagonal as your king so
there will be bishop d4 check ideas in
those lines and that's actually
pretty crazy because it seems like
white's you know all safe and sound
but at the end of the day notice when
pieces on the same diagonals each other
that could
backfire yeah rook f7 played so
uh unfortunately lawrence was maybe not
thinking tactically enough
could have got away with the knight
first but he recognizes that hey those
queens come off
this could be bad news for me so he
wants to stop the invasion there
he has given up the c8 square which has
been used
queen c8 check um and if the rook gets
to c7 obviously
that would be uh very very good for
white but i'm not quite sure how that
can happen bishop f8
but the thing about this is if you
played bishop effete or knight of fate
you just
worsen your piece you would love to play
king h7 here if the knight
were already on f6 your king would have
an escape square although the f5 pawn
would be hanging but the rook didn't
have to leave that fate i guess that's
the
essential point of this black is now
tied down again right what what are your
next two moves for black like king h7
and
maybe knight g6 or something like that
right yeah maybe king
king h7 but it's not the fastest no it's
not
it doesn't feel like it has that kind of
force so if i am roberto here
i may even just think can i push my pawn
to b6 somehow can i play b5
move my knight play pawn b6 maybe knight
to a5 go after your b7 pawn
it's a lot to ask for but i think that
black is much slower in the approach now
that you had to retreat your knight to
f8
yep no that's a good point like as soon
as the rook gets to c7
it feels really good i'm almost looking
at knight a8 rook c7 like as strange as
it is
just to get the rook there and then it
looks like you win that pawn on v7
i kind of like knight eight it's funky
it
may not be objectively the best move but
it has that clear purpose as you're
saying and
you can also push the b pawn up
establish that rook on c7
and i'm not sure how black intends to
meet that yeah it's just like um
the the way that i would be afraid of
black replying to that would be
if this queen just sort of gets in the
position in any way if it just gets down
queen b2 queen a1 once the rook gets
down here i'm i'm
very scared uh that's why i think the
evaluation bar is hovering
uh very close to the middle which which
means that
um not that we're heading over as a draw
robert but that this
could definitely go either way and i
think it has a lot to do
with these queens being on or off the
board but let's see
that's a great move queen e6 and the
point is you give up your
d5 pawn which goes to e6 black can win
it but this rook c7 idea is too powerful
because if we trade
black's rook slides to e7 to win the
pawn the white knight comes to d5
and the rook has to take the pawn the
rook comes to c7 you establish dominance
on the queen side
and this is very common in these kind of
positions even at the cost of a pawn
getting the d5 square for your knight is
so valuable
yeah and that knight is really powerful
protects f4
the f4 pawn keeps every single piece out
of the e5 square
it's like this f4 pawn is actually
dominating the black pieces
you might might not even recognize that
it's hard to hard to tell
the impact but this pawn is huge right
now for sure and look at this from
knight c hitting the queen hitting the
d6 pawn the queens have to come off
because the rook and f7 needs a defender
as well so i really like
this move knight c8 and i guess for
lawrence you don't want to trade queen
to
maybe queen f8 but that looks like
you're on your back foot while white is
making progress and i understand
what lawrence was doing he went h4 to go
bishop h6 get this f4 pawn
and it couldn't be protected but wait e7
he wants
e7 rookie 6 rook c7 though
and then he's going to like move his
king go bishop f6 but
it seems slow the only saving grace for
black is if this pawn
somehow gets rolling if it doesn't get
picked up here then it goes d5 d4
that's true and look at look at roberto
says i'm gonna start bishop d4 because
if you move your rook
i'm going to play rook c7 and pin your
bishop on g7 that's
probably just game right that looks like
a great move that looks
pretty gamey
[Laughter]
yeah it's i mean rook c7 is next i think
if you're lawrence you just have to take
on e6
your opponent doesn't have that much
time left play like 95 right
it's funny we had the same exact thought
here but it's because we've played
enough you know speed chess bullet chess
in particular where
sometimes you just make a confusing move
and play it quickly and then your
opponent doesn't have time to work
through the complications even if they
are
objectively winning so if pawn takes
pawn takes now you have the f and
both of the e pawns rolling and that
could spell trouble for white
yeah i know this is like probably very
over but
it doesn't feel that winning for white
yet
like we're very close to that level um
but i'm
i'm looking at like uh knight takes d6
ideas um looks really strong um
taking here and i don't know how that
end game goes but to my eyes you
something like getting the move king to
f2 and g3 and you win with two pass
pawns
right and actually we see our
resignation and the reason why is
i guess he wouldn't take on g7 for a
turn he just pushes b-pawn first
and the king wouldn't be able to stop it
so now that was really instructive
technique by roberto and
honestly it's one-to-one and it seems
like the games
have been dictated by the styles of the
position in game one lawrence was a
great look at this we have
an italian turned into a duboff when he
beat sergey karjakin with his crazy b4
move
so this is lawrence's style once again
roberto wins with the white pieces
in his style like more closed position
where he could outplay lauren so
i don't know all the theory here i just
know that dude beat karjakin in this
line and that means it must be scary
yeah and i think i think at the end of
the day if
if uh duba does something like this
lawrence is going to be
one of the first uh you know
practitioners uh
lawrence loves this stuff anyway and i
know that feeling when you have a
certain style and you see someone
emulate it at the top level you're like
wow
you know this is unbelievable they're
showing how to do this
against guys of world uh you know
world-class caliber
uh you know i'm i want i want some of
that to
uh i want that rush that feeling and it
makes sense to me that lawrence is
picking up this
this opening here and i'm sure no doubt
that he knows a thing or two about this
it's quite possible he knows it a bit
better than his opponent which is
already
you know some type of advantage to speak
of yes because this is a very
risky variation i mean look at black's
position right now
the material is even it right
it doesn't even look like it but black
has six pawns
white has wait why is seven pawns now so
now it's no longer even
but you can take you could take on d4
and restore the material quality but
this is such a wild looking position and
that's what lawrence is counting on it's
not the objective value
so much as the practical force of this
when you're playing with under five
minutes in the clock
yeah yeah it's more that uh lawrence is
gonna
you know own the dark squares so to
speak the knight on a5
is quite offside and there's also that
element of
surprise i don't know how surprised
roberto is here but
let's just say there's that element of
surprise that you feel like you're
bringing
the other player into your prep or your
style your game
rather than the other way around so
lawrence gets to play uh more in the
style of game one
and less in the style of game two where
things did not go his way he
was not able to get an attack going
speaking of styles and surprises
roberto played e5 on the first from this
game i didn't even register that but he
played the keracon
in game one and now he played e5 so are
we gonna see
different openings pretty much every
game is that the type of player roberto
is going to be
today obviously most of these titles
strong players can play a variety of
styles
but i just realized that we have a
different opening and that's why
this kind of crazy position uh was able
to be reached on the board
and do you think we have a different
opening because he's playing different
uh styles or because he got rocked in
game one
and he's like okay let's put that carrot
gun on the back burner just for a couple
games
get that confidence back maybe he's
gonna look at it in the break and then
bring it back
um the car con i feel like is not an
opening where
uh you have to play the same line over
and over like i think he can change that
up pretty easily
but um is he gonna is he gonna amend
that before he plays it again that might
be the question
yeah it's a great question and for
lawrence he's capable of playing pretty
much any opening himself
so here we continue our tactical flare
and this pong went to g3 that's bad for
the light squares and guess what
only black has a light square bishop but
at the same time that knight and a5 is
still stuck and out of the game
the king that's castled queenside can
get under fire when your king's on
opposite side of the board
hey you know if my king is safe i'm just
going to go all in
against your king so right now black
needs a move the queen's under attack i
would
not take on d4 that feels pretty risky
to allow some kind of
bishop to beat two or rook d one first
and then you should be two giving you
the night for free
for free in quotes because i wouldn't
yet uh but
i think you just need to move the queen
and roberto taking his time wisely oh
he takes yeah i mean so this move was
just in time knight c3 by lawrence
because bishop h3
uh was about to be in the position by
black
now i'm surprised by a lot of these
moves because i thought
after queen d4 that we were on the same
page rook d1
and if queen takes c3 you just trade the
rooks on d8 and go bishop b2
or just bishop b2 straight away and
you're picking up that free rook
on g7 as for this bishop e2 doesn't look
like a terrible move but
um it does look like maybe some chances
where miss rook d1 looked really active
and quite forcing
yeah this is the difference between
seeing tactics generally and
specifically
lawrence understood that there's a
problem for black taking this pun on d4
he saw his bishop going to b2 instead of
sitting behind a pawn it now has
the length of diagonal so he recognized
that queen 64 he had something
he just didn't do the precise move order
and now look what roberto does say hey
queen d3 don't mind trading queens if
you take me i have a past pawn the c4
square is vacated for
my knight and if you try to keep the
queens on the board where is your queen
going like are you
really going to give me control of your
light square as your king is not very
safe
and maybe in fact black can play move
like queen to c or d2
and go after this bishop on b2 and the
knight on c3 so there's
too much going on here i believe for
white to keep the queens on the board
and that's why we just saw rook to d1
yeah and i was almost wondering about
queen d3 because i thought queen d2
maybe was more forcing
to really get those queens off the board
hitting the queen and the bishop
um the reason that that tactic was
missed and it's actually kind of a big
deal is that the rook on g7 it wasn't
coordinated with the rook on d8
anytime you can make a an exchange of
rooks and the king
has to like take and come towards the
center that always feels like a good
sign so
i think roberto has emerged with a great
position
lawrence is not going to be happy
playing that type of opening and then
having to just trade queens
into an end game where he's actually
just one pawn down and he could take on
a5 which would leave black with
one of the ugliest pawn structures i've
ever seen with double iceland a pawns
double isolated c pawns
but you have a pass pawn on c4 and your
rook even though it was a problem piece
on g7 before
that rook can even slide up via g5 or
something like that
so i do like black's chances here this
is the type of position roberto
could only have dreamed of considering
how wild the game was before this
but as you said him on he's up a pawn
and if you start treading pieces
that extra pawn will make itself felt
yeah and you know if this uh knight
reroutes to
d6 i think that that would be quite good
is he going
here and then taking and going rook c1
that's actually what i thought he was
gonna do
okay but i like rook g5 here i'll give
you the e6 pawn to take your b5 pawn
like
that one's hanging and if you play a4 to
defend now my knight finally has an
active free square to go to with the b3
square so
he plays rook d8 instead i guess he's
just trying to go rook d3 and
just wants the pawn to go but can you
just take and go rookie three
i think so yes um because one thing to
not underestimate
at all is a bishop against a knight
if white just has one pass pawn over
here it might compensate for like
oh the entire queen side right and
oh so by the way i really like that
knight b7 move because
he did not want to allow the bishop to
take at that point as he's
two pawns down on the king side and now
take on b5 you can't take on c4 because
rook d1 check rook c1
pinning the bishop he overlooked it i
could i could tell he had overlooked it
just by the way he was playing
but now he has officially overlooked it
and rook d1 rook c1 just wins a piece
yeah and it's funny because almost
looked like he overlooked it but now
it's very clear on the webcam
yeah lawrence overlooked that oh he was
just distraught
he was you know beside himself there and
now roberto
is about to pick up his second game in a
row and
lawrence will have to go back to the
drawing board because this opening did
not
go the way he wanted it to well actually
kind of did but then he misstep by
playing bishop b2 so
he he had the craziness that he was
desiring but he didn't convert it
that well well the nice thing about his
position is that
you just play the pawns you don't
calculate you know
you're pissed off you you blunder to
peace hey at least take some solace and
just pushing these pawns blindly
you know amman it's probably too early
to think match strategy
but i know roberto is a fantastic bullet
player
i would consider resigning already if i
were lawrence not not
in this particular game but generally
speaking if you lose a piece sometimes
you just resign so you get more games in
but there are these three pawns here on
the king side for white so
lawrence should play this particular
game out i just thinking about it
in terms of the overall match picture
because actually white's pawns are
quicker right now
and it's possible that this blunder
turns into 40 because h6 how do you stop
the pawns
because you have g4 to stop the rook
like that
white's winning now according to the
engine rook g7
i mean basically push the pawn and
decide about the rook later
yes that's that's the way i'm i'm
thinking about it and you could have
played
the pawn to h7 you know rook hay check
pawn h7 so
this is just wild and now there may only
be like one
or two ways for roberts to hold i think
knight f5 is rook
g5 happening and how do you defend this
knight right if you play rook
c5 you walked into a pin so why can't
even start pushing the h pawn some more
this is
wow this is turning real fast so knight
h6 maybe just run around with your
knight
yeah i guess the well oh 93 check
if you move the king and then go g4
that feels pretty logical there's going
to be a rook check but
17 seconds for roberto i think we can
easily see lawrence winning this game
which is just absolutely crazy but if he
goes h6 now rook c6
you have to i thought you'd play rook c6
and just take the pawn directly
because the problem with this line is
you will win the h6 pawn but you're
losing
white's just better yeah you lost a very
important tempo because you're dropping
this pawn on
a5 i would have actually gone to g4 with
the king i know it looked like
counter-intuitive king g2 hits the rook
but king g4 is just like better place
for the end game
white should probably win this like i
feel pretty good
about lawrence's position here wow what
a turnaround this game has seen but
king d6 trying to go c5 look at roberto
very smartly saying i just need to push
my pawns don't play it now because the
rooks get traded
rook be a great move his technique at
this point in time
is perfect c5 c4 keep those pawns going
and unfortunately for white you're not
in time with your past pawns
and what a tale this has been amman
where at first you blunder a piece
then your pawns are really fast all of a
sudden black is down pawn but
his pawns are faster weird stuff and i
like this from lawrence i think the goal
is to just get your king in
um asap like king d4 rook c6 ideas
um just chase these guys down and then
connect your own pawns
right but b3 is happening that rook is
behind the past pawns be very careful
that you don't just allow this pawn to
go promote for black this is a point
it's so bizarre
yeah it's b3 or c3 he has a choice and
that's where it becomes a problem you
expect
c3 and then b3 happens but this is why
lawrence dropped his rook back
and now how do you go okay two seconds
you gotta move roberto
go oh my gosh and oh oh
oh we lost some time oh my goodness the
plus one is just
just not enough and lawrence is over the
moon
look at that reaction he blended a full
piece like the fullest piece you could
blender
wow that was unbelievable and lawrence
you could see how much he's putting into
this match at first he was
devastated that he blundered then he
calmed himself down
and he realized something that even i
wasn't realizing hey wait a second
my pawns are fast i still have a chance
here and he actually
wins that game and for roberto where did
all his time go
uh well it went into winning a piece and
then
uh not only overthinking but probably
miscalculating and totally missing the
right idea defensive idea
to stop those pawns because there's
always a balance between getting your
pawns going
and at some point maybe using the knight
to sacrifice for an advanced white bomb
but
what he ended up doing was was like the
worst of both worlds he didn't get his
pawn going quick enough he lost one of
his queen side pawns
and he didn't really stop the the h-pawn
without losing his piece so
uh just a disaster game and that's how
you until i mean lawrence was ready to
throw in the towel
and all of a sudden he's sitting up in
his chair and fist bumping at the end
yeah and now he's playing the bononi
where his knight on c7 looks absolutely
amazing
that is sarcasm that knight does not
look very good but this is a typical
plan can you get rook b8 can you play b5
i personally am not a big believer in
the benoni i think it just gives white a
very healthy position
but there are times you put b5 or play
f5 so it is
in lawrence's style and for me i just i
don't
personally like it but it is an
acceptable opening
we can use the term acceptable
yeah right it's it's fine you know it
has its
merits and uh well rook v8 i think his
intentions are quite clear
yep we want to play b5 and
what we see is a position where lawrence
is going to have a bit better control of
the
dark squares just because you know the
light square bishop has
traded for the knight on f3 at some
point in this game
and uh you know black's going to go like
knight d7 wants to have the e5 square
b5 at the moment roberto saying look you
know give me the a file and get my rook
down
a7 um at the moment i'm not sure
lawrence wants to open the position but
that is what he wants to do in general
and he's going to go b5 right if there's
any player who wants to play
aggressively it is lawrence trent
he goes b5 which is a good decision and
look at this this
e4 pawn looks strong but he can quickly
get in trouble so that's why roberto put
his knight to d1
but knight to f2 and he's keeping
everything i don't want to say safe and
sound but for now it's a pretty compact
situation
yeah i love knight b5 i think knight d7
some sort of knight d4
taking over some dark squares in the
middle of the board makes a lot of sense
although this pawn on e4 is defended
knight f2 bishop f3
it actually can't really advance that
easily unless you want
what i was going to say unless you want
to make things completely murky and
tactical
but not only does that play into the
style of number one lawrence trent
but number two the bononi as an opening
is ready for these types of skirmishes
in the middle
yeah although there is a bishop pair for
white so if the position opens up those
bishops can thrive and look at this
bishop f4
winning one of the rooks but look at
lawrence i don't care about that rook
look at my dark square bishop you take
me on e5
i take back but this is an important
lesson right now do i say i don't think
you should take
that rook couldn't move anywhere if you
move that rook you lose the other rook
so i think that
roberto had one move to use there and by
taking on e5 he helped lawrence
just say i'm gonna be in this material
deficit regardless but i
now have the activity because i get to
strike and it looked like he could have
used the knight knight d3 knight g4
put more pressure on that rook and if
you could take the rook with the knight
then i think lawrence's sacrifice is
simply not good that's true
and right now it's pretty double-edged i
would say that when i look at this you
have
a rook for a knight in one pawn but also
this opposite-colored bishop dynamic and
don't take on c5 now because bishop d4
check but
just in general the black controls the
dark squares white
doesn't really control the light squares
because the knight in excellent black
kitty piece
says your d-pawn's not going anywhere
your best move for white will be bishop
takes pawn on d5
you can't do that so the bishop on f3
doesn't really have
anything to boast about yeah and there's
an interesting choice there queen takes
d6
sort of speaks to getting that knight
into d4 but knight d6 the best blockader
in chess
supports the c pawn push that rook can
get behind and that pawn just
basically sits on c3 defended by the
bishop
i love the confidence that lawrence is
playing with in this game he didn't bat
an
eye when he lost that exchange i
or i don't even want to say lost that
exchange when he gave up that exchange
because that's just so thematic
it's exactly the way you want to play in
this opening plus if i had to take a
position i'm taking black here
oh me too and i think that lawrence is
to be a bit careful
because you do want to push this pawn to
c3 but you don't want to just
use all of your attention over there
right if you just get tunnel vision that
could be a problem but i like his move
queen f6
he's using his queen as bishop he has a
much better situation
bishop on f3 it's not a good piece and
there's nowhere for it to go like if i
said
hey come on throw the bishop somewhere
you'd say okay i'll go to c6 that looks
good
good luck getting there right right and
it's not that much better but
you know you can't even get there so
that's the biggest problem in white's
position
is you can't use your extra material
well and in fact black with the c pawn
as you pointed out
it's just uh roaming down the board yeah
this
and it needs to be said like even move
like queen d4 if the queens get traded
it's not like roberto's position gets
that much better it might not help at
all like end games and he plays queen d4
like he even offers the exchange
takes takes rook d2 runs into bishop e3
so i think he's just going to go to e2
but it's just an example of like you can
trade queens while being quote unquote
down material because of how strong the
pieces on the board are
in black's position absolutely and when
you are ahead material like roberto is
by points
you want to think about how to give some
of it back that should be in the back of
your mind so if roberto can like play uh
some kind of like
rook takes c4 and give up his rook for
that knight in that pawn you would want
to do that it relieves the rest of your
position so
i like how robert just handling this the
last couple of moves but he's still in
trouble
yeah rook 8 played just thinking about
rook a2
like rookie a2 take on v2 got two pieces
there as soon as you get that b-pawn by
the way the
floodgates open like those two pawns
might even be worth sacking a piece
just to get that pawn depending on the
position i was thinking about that as
well like can i play some kind of bishop
takes b2 and give up my piece
of course lawrence shouldn't do that and
by the way both players have a lot of
time
when i'm looking at this position i
would expect them to be down to like 30
seconds
but they are moving very quickly and
they're both playing well
in this game so if you play rook a2 i'm
going to
probably have to do something like rook
to b1 and how does black proceed from
there
is going to be an important question and
the thing with rook d2 like if you just
look at white's last
you know almost 10 moves what is he
doing he's not doing anything
proactive it's all reactive and it just
means that
lawrence sort of has a free hand in this
game he can choose
do i want to push the tempo now do i
want to you know change the pawn
structure a bit do i want to
get my king in the middle um it seems
like lawrence can just decide how he
wants to play this game
um does he want to push the tempo or
play this game a little bit longer get
the clocks lower
i don't see any active plans that
roberto has he's sort of just shuffling
and defending yeah i think the one move
i would consider
here for roberto's bishop e4 just to
kick that rook out of b1
the knight does not want to take on e4
so at least i kick your rook away
and then i don't have a plan exactly but
i don't want to move threat
i can be happy about that yeah that's
something that's something it looks like
you know maybe pointing towards g4s
of the world uh with king h3 although
i don't think that's that's really what
you want to do here no
and lawrence uh for on his end he needs
to find the correct path for it
will it be c3 will it be b3 i like the
look of b3 you cement that pawn on
b2 and maybe you can go attack it but
the problem with playing b3
is that both of your pawns are on light
squares and it's not like the bishop
will go win those pawns but you have to
be careful about doing some of that
because when you push
the b pawn c3 becomes a bit less
powerful in many of the variations so
instead
lawrence wins rook to e1 the bishop to
g2 roberto is kind of aimlessly moving
around but at least he's doing it
quickly
because lawrence is now down what 40
seconds on the clock
yep he's down 40 seconds uh what i was
maybe thinking for lawrence is you know
almost put the pieces back where they
just came from
tried bishop e5 f6 and then
like some long king walk up to like c5
or even to like b5
a4 b3 um basically i feel like this king
needs to participate
i agree with you and lawrence is spoiled
for choice which is why he's spending so
much time look at him he is
upset he's frustrated because he knows
his position is better roberto knows the
same
but he's like what do i do he trades
rooks and that simplifies things and
sometimes
that will allow your plan of a king
march into the center and all that good
stuff
but that also means that you may not
have enough material remaining to press
for a win
yeah and the good thing at the moment is
the rook is stuck
to that b-pawn as soon as this rook you
know gets free
and can maybe approach the funds from
behind that's a whole different game
um i don't know whether i love or hate
the decision from lawrence right now
because you know f6 you know is a little
bit harder to do to run that king the g
pawn would be weak from the bishop
and right now bishop e2 is the idea to
try to hit that
to c4 pawn but i think that this is
still good for for lawrence i i don't
hate his decision
yeah it still looks pleasant for black
but
again it does he have enough material
remaining so b3 i like that move now
as white was going to play bishop e2
next and now the rook has to move away
and
black will play king f6 i don't quite
see
where finishing touch will happen but c3
will be a consideration in your future
and then put my pawn on b2 and just keep
you tied down so that's what
lawrence i think is going for he does so
and i'm not sure it's enough though
yeah i'm not sure it's enough i i think
with that plus one and the fact that you
can just throw that
pawn on b2 and have it protected
it should be at the very least solid but
what you're worried about is white you
know putting his bishop on c2 covering
that and then the rook suddenly is free
to play
the rook can just do things you don't
know what those are you know how
dangerous they're going to be
but for example the rook's cutting the
king off and that pawn
ever starts to move up the board it's
just curtains for black
that's right and the great thing about
obstacle bishops here is that you put
upon a b2 that pawn can't be attacked
the terrible thing is that the b1 square
is a light square so
as we're discussing here that you put a
bishop on b1 your bishop protects your
pawn but can't actually kick that
blockading piece out so
roberto's hanging on by a thread here
he's really just barely
holding things together but look at the
clock it is about to be even on time
that's good news for lawrence because
his position is better and it's much
harder to defend this as white
than it is to push with black yeah you
can just shuffle i mean
pawn there knight to a3 just as a simple
uh way to threaten b1 love the way that
lawrence has played this game like
start to finish maybe it wasn't perfect
but that's what chess is you're not
going to know the exact winning plan
lawrence was
poking and prodding around with his rook
with his pieces he's going to get this
pawn to b2
and i think he's done a fantastic job
let's see if he can convert
yeah i don't like defending the b1
square with the rook even though he's
keeping his d5 pawn
there could be i was about to say bishop
d2 next move bishop c1 and if the rook
has to go to b1 that rook is stuck there
this reminds me of niels grandilius
against jordan van forest
when the rook gets caught like that it's
just game knight c4 knight d2 and
that is game over um so as as you just
pointed out
i mean that once the knight comes in
it's okay knight c4 knight a3
knight e4 knight c3 lots of ways to do
it can't even play king e2
knight d2 is a fork oh that that's
painful
and what a win by lawrence trent i mean
he really played
a great start to this match with the
exception of game two right game two was
not
friendly to him and that's what roberto
needs to do we are taking
our half-time break here but aman what
advice would you give
to roberto to try to come back in this
match it's still pretty close
yeah very very close match uh three to
one he obviously had that
game that slipped away from him so in
his head it probably feels in terms of
how they've played or like a two-two
match
because he just slipped that game away
where he was up a piece so i don't think
roberto should panic at all
he might go and check that karo khan
because we know that he does love that
opening
so i would say just relax um you you
know you're the stronger
player on paper rather and i don't think
that he needs to panic
at all lawrence is playing great chess
but if roberto steps his game up
this match is going to be tied again in
no time for sure and speaking of
relaxing all you
relax take a brief break we will be back
in just a few minutes for more of this
match
between roberto molina and lauren shred
and we return with more action from this
fascinating battle between two of the
strongest ims we got
and amman it has been so great thus far
lawrence thriving
in those tactical positions but also
showing some classy end game technique
in that fourth game we just saw yeah i
gotta give a lot of credit to
lawrence not only in this match so far
because we've seen
so many different styles from him um
robert like i i feel like
right off uh the bat in game one we saw
his aggressive hey
take my pawn uh poison pawn variation
i'm just gonna storm the king style
and execute it very well then in
uh his other win we saw him blunder a
piece
and make a comeback stay in the game he
lost his confidence and he got it right
back
pushing those pawns claiming a win
somehow
at the end of that and then we see this
last game where
start to finish you know he stacks the
exchange plays a beautiful positional
controlled game
and executes in the end game it's like
oh we're seeing everything from lauren's
trent right now
we certainly are and he's been nervous
we saw his reaction when he blundered
that piece
but nerves are a good thing alexander
grisha said this he said
you know nerves are good it means i care
and so you
like to see when players are showing
their emotion but still controlled after
that fact so
lawrence three to one lead thus far for
roberto i feel like he needs to play
of course like he did in the second game
but you reminded me of the fact that he
was of a piece so he had that chance
to be level at this point and it's that
close of a match
right yeah so that that's the thing is
that uh roberto knows
he he's basically played well enough to
earn himself at least two wins
in this match so far so he can he can
tell himself that at all times what we
have here
is uh lawrence actually changing it up
right he played bishop
b5 one for the rui lopez instead of
bishop c4
from uh last game we were wondering if
he was maybe going to look at that line
and i wonder if he did look at it during
the break where you get a couple minutes
like well that didn't really pan out
roberto knew what he was doing let's go
for something
that's a bit more closed in nature but
speaking you know as we have been about
styles
this would seem at least on a high level
thought that it's good for roberto to
get into these positions
yeah i wonder um if lawrence
because of the fact that he uh does a
lot of commentary
on uh high-level matches like the world
championship
i wonder if he sees openings like this
in those matches a world championship
match candidates and
starts to implement them a bit more into
his own chess because
it's almost like this main main main
line very lopez it's one of the last
things i'd expect to see lawrence trent
playing
yeah especially in the blitz game it's
kind of odd but
we see this in the speed chess
championship when you know you have the
maxine vustrilla graves the world
playing but this is really mainline
stuff
but i do like lawrence's position this
knight on b7
is really not happy where is it going
from there and
roberto says yeah i'm just going to play
quickly i'll take on e7 please
queen takes e7 you're freeing up the
board for me
and i want to remind everybody that c4
square
is looking awfully juicy for a black
knight when you have pawns two squares
away from one another
look at the square in between that c4
square is blacks for the taking
at a later point yeah and i think that
explains
the move knight e3 perfectly i don't
even need to touch on that because
that watch is over that square we might
even just see c4
right now in the position it looks very
reasonable i know it looks funny
all four pawns up there on the fourth
rank but c4 looks
like a pretty good move and one of the
reasons i wanted to do that robert
before
bishop b2 was i wanted to you know do
the cheeky rook swing
get the rook into the center rook d2
rook e2 rook c2 before playing bishop b2
that makes a lot of sense because what
is that rook doing look he just won
bishop a1
probably because of what you were saying
and i think black
should have went for a strike with a5
because now after c4
a5 doesn't look nearly as appealing
there's a lot of tension in the center
that rook as you just pointed out i'm on
that can go to c2 now because
in line with the queen and go to d2 to
line up along that defile which is bound
to open up
or it can even go to e2 if you need to
defend that pawn so you're right i
like white's position now lawrence is
handling this well and roberto
he just feels like he's floundering a
bit he doesn't have a concrete plan
and now the position is about to open up
and that bishop on a1 watch out for that
piece
wow yeah that's going to be very strong
the only thing about lawrence's position
is
he's kind of lost the move like bishop
b2 bishop a1
and in a lot of cases you actually want
your bishop to be on b2
just because it controls a few more
squares so
um if the rook was already in the center
somewhere and bishop on b2 i think it'd
be a little bit better but
hey you can't have everything this
knight on b7 as you mentioned is still
out of the game you know almost wants to
go to d8 and e6 just to play
just to have some scope but uh e4 pawn
taken
and all i can say is that bishop on a1
we mention how dominant is going to be
taking on e4 looks greedy and it doesn't
look like he has the position to justify
uh you know taking the time uh to take
that pawn
i already see a ton of different ideas
for why queen c2 hits the rook
now you're throwing c takes b5 when the
c pawn for black cannot recapture the
queen is hanging down the file
so after cb5 the c6 pawn will be white
and that's an important pawn because yes
black stole a central pawn
but i'm splitting your pawns on the
queen side if i take out c6 but i can
also play knight d5 just continue
pushing forward here he takes on c6
which is good right this is a great
position for white
but he could have been tactical with
knight to d5 yeah it could have just
combined them knight d5 and then queen
c6 and then both knights get in there
like this knight on b7 is
still just not participating at all
no and it may have to go to d8 to just
trade off or something like that but
look at this roberto gains a tempo
essentially white could have had the
same
queenless position with a knight on d5
but black gets the knight first and now
black can play d5 and that knight on b7
may come to d6
and into the c4 square that we talked
about so long ago
and it's funny how that one little extra
tactic it's like the sprinkle
that robert's putting on top of the uh
the cupcake
because queen takes c6 is a great move
but knight d5 taking advantage of the
pin
would have stopped knight v6 would have
stopped d5 would have stopped knight d6
and
black's whole activation plan to get
back in this game it looks like it's
it's just a product
of not putting that that little knight
d5 move in it seems to be making all the
difference
it certainly does and black is now
freeing up the board for the bishop on
the fade the knight on b7
and as is typical in the rolo pez if
your knight is stuck on b7 your position
often is very terrible
anatoly karpov can teach everybody
finger three about that
and right now lawrence plays g3 he's not
happy to make that move
knight d6 knight c4 black's pieces are
just going into the board here
it's like flying freely yeah i i mean
the
it looks like rook d1 is also an idea to
to get that on knight c4 is he trying to
say look
take that pawn i take on a3 and and then
the knight on b7
is already got that d6 square it just
looks like it's getting closer and
closer to it's just an equal position
yeah i agree and i do wonder why he left
his knight on b7 he was going for like
the quick
pounce of like knight c4 i'm going to
threaten the a3 pawn
but the knight on b7 is still a
problematic piece and even if it is
level
i feel like the game was turning in
black's favor
so bringing the knight out from the
wayside into the action
could have been beneficial for black not
just to equalize but even to play for
more
yeah i like the idea of move ago knight
d6 because then if rook d1
knight c4 from the d-file and if knight
takes d5 there's always this rookie one
trick
to win the piece on d5 so it's kind of a
nice way to
get the c4 square but not let white
execute maybe the plan that he's going
for
which is just to probably uh say look i
see the the
the black pieces coming into the game
let's just equalize things and
not let this get out of hand and lauren
spent some time
quickly responds with rook a2 that rook
can come to a7 at some point
i don't think i would do it just yet but
that's the thing knight c3 hits the rook
on e4 or the pawn on b5 but then the
pawn b4 is hanging in return because
that nine
oh actually there's a knight c6 two both
of them are protecting so maybe you can
play knight c3 and just go after the b5
font
it's funny there's so many like knight
c7 uh
knight a7 knight c3 knight d4 there's so
many ways to hit
that d-pawn uh it'd almost be a shame at
this point if he didn't manage to get
his hands on it
um it does look like the most likely
scenario though
is both sides win the respective b-pawns
and you know from there it just sort of
equalizes but
the time advantage that roberto has
could be maybe the
so far that's the biggest difference in
the position both sides active pieces
all around look at the time though a
minute and a half plus
yeah and there's something long-term
that i believe lawrence is struggling
with
the bishop on a1 looks beautiful on the
board's longest diagonal
but there's a pawn on b4 that's on a
dark square so if the knights come off
the board all four of them
black's bishop can attack white's pawn
and then white's pawn has to resort to
defense so that's something to look for
if you're roberto and you're trying to
figure out
hey can i actually try to squeeze this
equal position into a win
rookie 2 is a great start of course
that's an active move but i'm just
thinking about what pieces i want to
trade
and if the knights come off white is the
one who's stuck with a
worse pawn yep and rook e2
uh threatens ideas like rook d2 hey move
your knight
well you're walking into knight e3 fork
using that pin on the f-pawn
and you know just rook d2 other rook
down to e2
feels like roberto is making easy fast
moves and look at that time tick down
for lawrence he comes with each four i
think we're slowly seeing this tick
you know in in black's favor here as he
plays h5 so now he has an escape score
for the king
right and if you toss an hour on each
player's clock it still is a difficult
position to figure out
but you see lords in 18 seconds he is
two minutes behind on the clock
so if i'm roberto i'm just keeping
things a bit sharp knight f5 threatens
93 check
and it's not about going for one move
tactics it's just putting your opponent
in as difficult spot as possible
that could be with a simple move but
sometimes you have to be aggressive 94
hits the f2 pawn how do you even defend
that
bishop comes d4 mind
because the bishop on a1 is just not a
good piece anyway as you pointed out so
at least we can centralize that the rook
t8 move is not possible
those knights actually do control a fair
few amount of squares rook c8
to hit the knight just blunders
everything away with 97 check now
good call 97 check is something that
white can rely on and
i would probably play my knight from c4
to d6 and over to f5
and that's mainly because of the time
situation but that bishop on d4
is defending f2 if i can somehow get
that piece off the board
then the white king and in particular
pawn f2 get in danger so i think
knight c to d6 makes some sense but
maybe i'm overlooking some kind of
counter for white but 10 seconds that's
what i'm really looking at
exactly um as white like as lawrence i
am moving that king
sometime soon you know king f1 king g1 i
just have to get out of the way
the rooks are forked the rooks are
forked
there's no way out of this he walks
right into a fork
well he thought he was it's one of those
things you think you're hitting the
knight
and oh my goodness he's totally he's
totally botched this one
again we see roberto right at the end of
the game when he seems like it's
trending in his favor
he's messing things up and he can't even
play g6 here to protect the h5 punk
because rook a rook h8 checkmate that
bishop on d4
it's been the best piece it thrives
right now so
roberto is down a rook for a knight and
one point it's very confusing
lawrence has 6.5 seconds left so i would
probably play rook d6 here
pin that bishop and then lawrence figure
out wait do i need to protect my work on
d1 or
just leave this here what do i do and
you guys rook to a1 and oh that's a good
move
very very good move and a practical
choice of that
love that by uh by lawrence just the the
the understanding that oh young peace
young people protect that
my goodness yeah i can't get around
complimenting people i'm gonna stop that
you know as soon as you went to
compliment him he drops the piece but
the position was complicated look at how
many minor pieces were concentrated
in a very few amount of squares so rook
a7 i like that you're trying to take f7
you are down material it's two pieces
against a rook
knight of four check where's that king
going e7
okay king if you're a king six knight of
four back
king six i take the g7 pawn as well oh
wow yeah that's even worse so you have
to go back to g6 i guess
i think he's got his like pseudo draw
here unless he wants to give the f7 pawn
really go for it he's not happy maybe
rook takes f4 just
sacrifice your rook bishop c3 pawn b4
there he goes
energy there he goes i don't like f6
though whoa
rook b7 was needed there yes rook takes
d2
oh my gosh blunders galore here
oh that's a hole no that can't be good
this is just the nervousness the time
trouble yeah
black might win this game still like
black's king could try to
kick that rook out of there but look at
lawrence in time to bring his king
around
oh my gosh just in time for c4
oh not f3 get king g3 oh
there goes the g6 pawn this is and there
are kings cut off as well
yeah this is good this isn't good king
of the board king e3
i would cut that king off king d3 i like
that
and you can't play c2 too soon now you
were threatening z2 but because the
pawns promotion rook g6 is needed maybe
uh but the pawn is going to have f4 no
this looks like it should be a draw
if black establishes that pawn on the
dark square and the bishop defends both
it feels like we're heading toward the
draw but this game can last forever
he's going to build up some time which
is absolutely the way to do things
um the question really is
after he has all that time what can you
do with it and i'm not sure
that i know yeah the answer is
he has time but his pieces don't have
freedom here so like
he's just stuck like he king can't go
over the king's side because the c pawn
is free otherwise the rook has to go
defend and draw by repetition makes
sense
and i don't i don't think in this
particular position at the end that
either player is going to be too upset
with that result
but i think both players should be upset
in general both players had had
opportunities to win that game at
various points
and it wasn't just like they each had
one chance no
they each had multiple chances that's
very true and look at
lawrence he's playing b6 bishop b7 you
know he's trying to
hit at white center but this is already
a roberto opening the other pawn
triangle now he pushed up on e4
very solid here so i like this for
roberto compared to the bononi even if i
personally don't like the binoni i think
that it suits lawrence and roberto
struggled with it a bit
yep and there's no no shame in admitting
that especially in a match you don't
have to
don't have to put any uh any ego there
just play the openings that that seem to
be benefiting you
um it doesn't matter their reputation
knight h5
and lawrence is he's got that bishop
that never looks too great
against uh you know pawn chain like that
and the question is always
am i going to reroute that bishop or am
i going to leave it there pressuring
that pawn
just go for f5 and then put the pressure
on the d-pawn
and the e4 pawn to loosen up that punch
chain right this is thematic
and you would prefer that your piece had
a little bit more space for black but
that's why the move
f5 is so powerful you're trying to crash
through in the center you're trying to
give your pieces more space
one of the knights maybe the d knight
comes over to f6 but either way roberto
is struggling to come up with a move
he has plenty of time the game has just
started but amman when i look at this
position i think okay do i want to take
on f5 but then g takes f5 there could be
e4 maybe i'm walking into a pawn storm
that might not be so good but if i leave
the tension in the center at some point
is black just going to collapse it with
f takes e and knight to f6 and the d5
pawn
is weak i don't really want to play pawn
to c4 but that is what he just chose
i wanted the c4 square for my knight
that's really the essence of it
yeah and i think f4
makes makes a lot of sense here now in a
position like this
i'm a little bit more concerned about
stuff like taking on f5 like knight h4
um and putting pressure on f5 and also
of course queen
uncovering the attack on the h5 knight
so knight f1 played f4 still looks good
especially the knight were not on d7
f4 would look great so uh lawrence takes
and goes knight f6 but
the bishop on e4 isn't that important of
a piece you can retreat it of course
but you know it it's weird because
you've
thrown a fiance pawn structure but i
feel like you want to just blockade the
squares like knight d2
if it didn't block your bishop would
have been a good move just so you can
keep blocking that
e4 square and knight f3 to d2 that was
so i wouldn't walk into pins
and bishop g4 seems annoying
like that's a nasty pin there's there's
no h3 to kick it out
bishop g4 seems like a great start
especially with that rook on
on f8 um that's that looks good but
the question is after knight e3 bishop
takes
queen takes you you're looking at that
rook bearing down on the queen on c
uh on f3 but there's not really any good
squares to put your knight
yeah it's so annoying when it happens
like what i just lined everything up
perfectly
and yeah i can't take advantage of it
and that's a really good point and you
also don't want to allow white to
blockade the e4 square if that knight on
f3
just could go diagonally for a turn to
go to e4
now your bishop on g7 is stuck that
doesn't look great so e4
is thematic i'm not sure if it's good
because you drop a pawn by making play
e4
but that's that's kind of thing i'm
looking at just to free up black's
pieces
right and knight g for a totally
different approach
but the exact same goal which is
basically put pressure on f2 that's what
e4 was all about as well e4
maybe knight g4 was to follow now we see
knight g4 first
and the idea of like maybe queen f6 next
sometimes there's even sacrifices
on f2 followed by like bishop g4 things
to get
really really spicy here um you know
pawn sacks and p
sacks galore in in the position here so
i think that
this is just getting towards the
position that lawrence is turning into a
tactical struggle
yeah i would play bishop g5 for white
and then play knight
f1 to d2 and try as best as i can to get
my knight to e4 because i know if my
knight gets to e4
f2 is safer i'm also attacking this d6
pawn so that's what i'd be looking for
if i were roberto and it's about even on
the clock both sides
playing deliberately clear plans i
like the way this game has gone for
black but i'm worried about the long
term the strategic
risk that is inherent to this kind of
position and it's that pawn on d6 the
backward pawn
and knight on e4 blockades the center
and threatens it
yeah knight on e4 as you just brought up
is a great piece
um that just controls everything so i
just i like the flow
of your bishop g5 knight f1 to d2
and then if the bishop gets attacked it
can always come back to e3 and white's
not that concerned about losing that
bishop you know go ahead and take me
i might even play tigs on e3 slide the
pieces over to the open f file
and remember trades here are not only
good for the position but they're good
for roberto as a player
he seems to be doing well when he can
take things to an end game more
positional struggle
and really take it to lawrence and
that's why i think
lawrence it's in his style to play a
move like e5 to e4 at some point
even if it gives up a pawn the bishop
slicing through the board from g7 that
could be
really helpful to the attacking chances
and you have to time it well you can't
just do it
hey it looks good no it has to really
work
i think that roberto he needs to move
because he plays knight f
what's rook f takes up two oh my god
that's
that's like didn't he think for like two
minutes on that move and lawrence is
like sitting back in his chair like
did he just do what i thought he just
did he has no idea what's going on
and look at roberto's face he hasn't
flinched
but well that's because lawrence could
be looking at the camera you know he
can't
can't let your opponent know that you
just completely blundered
the only intention of knight g4
i will say and maybe this is just trying
to justify
a big blunder is that if you can play 94
and you don't get checkmated the 94 is
really powerful and sometimes
is worth the cost of a pawn you
mentioned how with the f file open you
can slide your pieces of the f file
that still holds true like white's next
move the rook goes back to f7 it could
be knight to e3
will trade knights you know all of a
sudden white's pieces are doing better
so it costs you material but you feel
like you have a healthier position
remaining it still is a pawn though
so so let me get this straight robert
you're saying that
roberto molina found a way to open the
f-file without trading pieces do i hear
you right
i'm just saying that i'm just trying to
justify it it was a blunder like it is
i yes the rook on f8 the 9g4 were
clearly hitting this pawn f2 so
i'm trying my best here i'm on i'm
trying my best
well i mean i'm not going to hate on
that knight on e4 that's exactly where i
wanted it
hopefully with all the pawns intact but
roberto's gonna make the best of it
and uh knight e3 is looking at three
more pieces get them off the board
the queen on f8 guards the pawn on d6
and i think roberto's just giving his
head that shake of like
okay that was a terrible blender that i
just did but
at the same time we can we can work with
this you know this is not
is not over it's far from over because
the extra pawn on e5
normally when you have extra material
and if pieces get traded you want to
have a past pawn
it's not that easy to push that pawn so
roberto's position
is worse there's no denying that but if
the queens come off now
like how is black going to win this game
that sort of the burden
is on lawrence to prove that he can win
his position is great
no denying yes but maybe roberto has
some chances
definitely if that knight was on e4 i
mean i think that maybe more than
chances
i think it was actually really good that
lawrence played the move knight f2
which sort of went unnoticed but it
traded away the knight on e4
and uh it means that the knight on e3
just is not attacking the d6 pawn while
blockading as well
it's a good piece but i think that was
actually really smart by lawrence
yeah he's playing this part perfectly
look at this bishop on h3 there's no
rook f1 for you
the knight and f6 there's nothing coming
to e4 and now knight g4
is an idea for black saying let's trade
off the knights get my bishop of g4 i'll
use the f-file
not just to say hey my rook looks good
but to even attack
bishop h6 is another move for black
we've been talking about a bishop
staring into its own pieces
why not trade it for that good knight on
e3
yeah and knight g4 immediately not only
does it prevent g4
but i mean this looks fantastic i i like
the move e4
by black getting the pieces out maybe
just taking advantage of the open file
bishop d4 bishop takes b2 i think rookie
8 if you take it obviously like this is
just
all flowing beautifully and rook f1 is a
necessary move because
if the trade happens b2 hangs but so
does e4
at least white has some chances it's
only one pawn that's
an important pawn and black is going to
play with a free hand
but the material if it starts trading
off there could be chances to hold so
look at this move look at it i
like that it's just beautiful yes really
really well played
the clock all of a sudden robert's gone
to 18 seconds and lawrence has it
over a minute and a half and remember
last game where was lawrence in time
trouble and then roberto went rookie six
and then dropped in exchange
at that moment lawrence is keeping up
the pressure look at this
bishop d4 please take me help my pawns
push forward here
lawrence is really in good shape right
now he is and
and bishop d4 is one of those moves that
is not what you want to see when you
have 18 seconds ticking down
no your pieces are frozen right you know
you don't want to take
but you also don't want to move the
bishop because the b2 pawn is hanging so
you're just stuck in place
yeah he needs moves he's i don't even
see moves at some point
bishop d1 is a good move all things
considered because if we trade bishops
then my king just comes to e2 and once
again i'm going to ask that question is
how does black make progress you have
an extra e pawn but i can blockade it
with my king and
where are you going from there right
yeah bishop
the the light squared bishops are
actually the ones you sort of want on
the board
as black based on you know the c4 pawn
and the d5 pawn if you were to trade on
c3
and keep those bishops you would have
pretty good chances in the enemies
you're gonna go like bishop
g2 no okay he is going to trade yeah and
well
i'm serious though where two from here
i'm trying to figure out how black does
this mean rook e5 pawn b5
but you can't move your rook off the e
file without dropping this pawn e4 so
even if you try to
break open the position there are some
drawbacks that are very clear so
how does black make progress here
hmm yeah maybe like king g7 g5 king g6
uh kind of stuff you should take c4
bishop 64 was a free pawn
dude you played e3 there oh my god yes
and okay he's going rook f2 check and he
still has some chins but
black could lose this game a timely rook
e6 will win the d6 pawn
and i cannot tell you how many times
this has happened to me
oh i'm playing really well i'm up a pawn
i get to an end game i'm up a pawn
trading down is good but you lose the d6
one and also lawrence now at 15 seconds
roberto has four seconds remaining and
lawrence is having a struggle here
yep okay just go right back to e4 next
and then rookie six just start
pre-moving
here comes oh white can easily win this
game rookie six
and this is scary no it is really scary
play rook e6
oh but there's then you can take the
pawn yeah the h4 pawn and then e2 like a
sacrifice at some point
is just trying to promote the d-pawn for
g4
richard d7 virtue d7 just push the pawn
oh wow that's amazing that's why
king c4 i think the king could start
running up the board here yeah i think
so he's gonna realize that right now
here it comes here it comes watch out
king d5 i think white's winning yeah for
sure winning
rook d4 i don't know d7 d7 and then rook
d4 doesn't work and now the c pawn runs
hang on yeah
wait what just happened ricky two
doesn't work
yeah i was trying to go over d2 too i
was like wait but no this is winning for
white all of a sudden
this is completely winning now a
whirlwind by the way if this rook were
behind the pawn which is where it
typically wants to be
black would have been able to push those
pawns so because it was on the second
rank it covered both
wow and the same thing that happened to
roberto just happened to lawrence right
which is
completely winning you have the upper
hand it was a piece earlier
now it was only a pawn but it was a pawn
plus everything that comes with it
so this was you know definitely at the
same
level of the previous advantage that
roberto had and messed up
so lawrence has just experienced
everything
every emotion in in this match robert
and he is leading this match still
and we're getting back to the game one
position but roberto looked at this
you can tell roberto quickly changed his
move order
and now he stretches e5 and it's up to
lawrence to justify his pawn sacrifice
he has
plenty of life in this position all of
his minor pieces look at them in the
center you can castle going in the
f-file
but you are down upon so we'll store
that for just a second and what i want
to say quickly that
even though lawrence is up a point in
this match he may not feel that way he
just lost the game where he was up a
pawn a clean pawn
where he was out playing his opponent so
he probably is feeling a bit down on
himself as most chess players do
when they fail to convert and not just
that they end up losing a game they have
no business losing
and can we talk about how wildly
different
roberto's position is you remember the
first time they played this line
it was a closed position there was a
king on g3
now it's like hang on knight takes e3
that's the most important piece on the
board for white
and black just castles and puts a knight
on e5 i mean what's going on here
lawrence's position looks
very bad to me and it's gonna be needed
to be tactically justified i think
right and that's why knight d to b5 was
played
and i'm trying to figure out like should
i take that knight or should i just drop
my
queen to e7 he drops queen e7 and the
biggest difference
is like the flow of white's pieces with
these two knights on c3 and b5
even though white keeps the material you
can't jump around with your other pieces
quite as well so that's a very
interesting moment there
by uh roberto to just play queen e7
you're already up some material the
bishop on e3 is under attack
i can take the knight on b5 next turn
let me just make sure i'm not getting
checking queen e5
queen e5 hits h2 and c3
what move is knight a7 this move is
absolutely wild to me
i this it's like a form of tilt almost
yeah knight takes a7 is just
ludicrous like the knight isn't
attacking anything it's now trapped
the the threat is knight takes e3 what
blacks about to castle
white's position is just shambles bishop
takes c3
knight takes e3 they're both hanging by
some
you know but some way or another black's
gonna win
huge and that's why lawrence is saying
all right look we're we're just going
all in get to get the bankroll out we're
going knight d5
yeah but if politics queen takes e3 is
checked so you steal a bishop and trade
the queens
you would not be able to take on e3 of
the king run h1 because rookie one ideas
with a pin
so i think lauren's gonna try nice c8
here just to uh
say i'm losing a piece regardless let me
keep on having some fun
but after knight c8 there could be queen
c7 something like that to threaten mate
on h2 and
get the queen out of trouble but then
there's bishop f4 so you have to be
careful still if you're roberto
yeah i'm just trying to think of the
material because if you go knight c
queen c7 bishop f4 you just
take on c8 and castle um and you're
gonna be up a piece
you know what's funny is i wasn't
actually visual even though i said
knight c8 i wasn't visualizing the
knight being on c8
so i was like oh what do i do after
bishop f4 well we take c8 is a free
beast there so yeah that's a good call
oh man he does yeah so of course he is
in a plane a c8
he's not happy about it um and roberto
is just i mean he's got four and a half
minutes it's a five minute game
this might actually end so quick we get
another five minute game which is crazy
uh it's two and a half minutes ticking
down on the match clock but we might
actually get another one
because this is so bad for lawrence
already question for you
if you're lawrence and let's say you
lose this game because it looks losing
do you just waste the rest of your time
do you essentially let your time run
until the five plus one segment is over
with
and then take your break and try to
refresh yourself i i think yes
um just because of how the last two
games have gone i don't think he's in
the right headspace to play more
five-minute games
and i think it just could be like more
of a surge for uh roberto
especially because you know he's about
to get the white pieces as well
i agree so queen takes c8 here you're up
a full piece you can just castle to
safety
and castle looks good yeah blacks up a
minor piece for
no compensation whatsoever but i think
lawrence is just
playing this out of the system that's
what i believe he's doing at this point
i'm dead lost i don't even have the
chances i did in the previous games
when i was losing i'm just going to play
some moves and
just try to forget it and if he wins it
he's going to be he's going to be
absolutely animated i can't
can't wait to see that kind of lawrence
because we saw
how he was after he won the game down a
piece so imagine if he wins this this is
totally over this is roberto's
game and roberto needs this win to tie
this match up at three and a half so
this is just absolutely crucial he can't
mess this up
yeah things started getting away from
lawrence in the draw when it was three
to one we had a break we got back
lawrence was in time trouble it felt
like he didn't quite feel at home
in this opening where we were saying
that's a what are we in the super grand
master classical tournament with that
white side of the lopez and he got a
good position but it was complicated
he was burning clock so lawrence needs
to find the opening weapons that suit
him i do believe that this opening
can be good for him it wasn't game one
but roberto studied it
and then said okay i'll handle it in a
more tactical manner myself and i'm not
material
yeah knight e4 here looks
like knight e4 the reason it looks so
good is that it trades every single
piece
so bishop on b3 is being hit by the
knight right now then
knight e4 hits the bishop on e5 and it
just means that everything disappears
from the board which is usually the
easiest way to
win the game when you're off material
yeah knight takes b3 94 bishop takes c5
rookie eight you you're up a full piece
and there's no attack because
none of white's pieces remain so roberto
he's got this one he's just spending his
time and he does in fact play knight to
e4
yep and we'll just see trades um
more trades i might i would probably
like take on b3 and just go maybe like
f5 or something
yeah or take and play rook e6 and take
this pawn on dc oh knight c3 is a tactic
coming up just right the full force
and time is officially up so knight c3
will win the game right now or f5 rookie
6 any of them
but the time it is up so we will
actually be ending the five minute
portion after this and it looks like
it's going to be tied up
wow and roberto he hasn't been to
like a motive there but he just
responded with like a like grabbed his
face like
i'm glad i just even the score up
because this has been a true
battle and aman i gotta ask you before
we go to break what are your thoughts
as we head into the three plus one what
does each side need to continue doing
and what does each player need to do
differently well roberto
needs to keep playing that character
because now it's up to lawrence to say
uh okay you know the first game might
have been great but this game was just
unacceptable this was just wild
terrible roberto clearly looked at this
and that paid off so
just those small fixes in the breaks
that roberto is doing are clearly
working for him
lawrence needs to get back to what
worked for him in the beginning part
right before we took her half time break
lawrence has been playing really good
chess and i hope that he just doesn't
forget that
um he doesn't think that oh uh this is
going terribly for me i'm playing poorly
and then maybe start playing out of tilt
with different openings quicker openings
i think he needs to maintain the fact
that this guy's higher rated than me but
i am sticking with him and going
toe-to-toe and i can play chess at his
level
i think there's a great point that the
results may be tricky to deal with
because while he's
lost a couple games here his play
overall has been exceptional
so you're right him on he needs to
remember that there were good times in
recent past
let them continue on we will take a
quick break in return we'll get right
back to this matchup in a short time
patrol in the i'm not a gm speeches
championship brought to you by chess.com
well if you can't stick around all day
on your computer watching amman and i
commentate this match you know go on the
go download the app
play some good chess play your friends
have a great time
and it's just it's free and you'll have
a good time playing so amman
as we get back to the over-the-board
action we have
lawrence we have roberto we have three
and a half points per side
who's gonna win this one my goodness i
mean this
this is uh i think you and i were
hinting at it before the match
um on and off stream that this was maybe
gonna be one of the closest matches one
of the hardest to call i was looking at
the chat
the the prediction poll for the five
minute portion
was roberto to win or lawrence to win or
draw
and it was 51 to 49 it's like literally
at
the closest i've ever seen the chatpole
uh you know for those
channel point uh degenerates and what we
see here is a tied match
going into the three minute portion um
what i see is that
if the tilt and the the effect of the
last couple games starts to affect
lawrence in what i can only imagine
should be a negative way
um if it starts to affect him at all i
think it will be negative and i think
that spells disaster for him
as roberto seems to have had a shaky
start but he's just starting to warm
up and i know firsthand you know how
tricky he can be in the bullet portion
lawrence is going to be very competitive
in bullet but i think roberto just has
that
that extra oomph that upper hand in
bullets so i'm
concerned that if things trend in that
direction
the bullet portion is going to favor him
it's more about whether lawrence
can get back to what was working at the
beginning
that's a fair point and the way i see
this match
i feel like i haven't found either
player separate themselves
because one game lawrence is down to 20
seconds the next game roberto's down to
20 seconds
and sometimes you see a trend of one
player is just getting time trouble
and that will never be good for them but
it's in a back and forth battle
of through and through and right now we
see the center locked up this bishop on
c8 is
starting there it hasn't gone to b7 and
the previous game
lawrence had to bring the bishop back he
did a great job doing so
but this could save him a tempo yeah
it's kind of
interesting because there's a line with
h3 bishop d3
and this pawn is on b7 so i don't know
whether it matters but there's a
there's a move pawn b6 which is there
for free
yeah and that could be a bad thing
though because the white knight can go
to d4 and into c6
uh right now knight d4 is tempting me
but i'm sure there are tactics
all across this board here black is
threatening to go b4 the b5 pawn is
hanging
you could take that but opening the b
file will allow the b2 pawn to feel
quite loose so instead roberto just
plays a3 the comma is moving the
position
and i think this is still theory more or
less i think it's a6
knight d4 bishop b7 um is sort of how
things go here but um this is again an
opening that
worked well for lawrence when he used it
last
so it makes sense that he's going back
to this yeah i actually find
white's position to be much harder to
play at this point because what's your
actual plan if i give white another turn
what are you gonna do there could be
some e5 tactics we saw roberto
rely on that in a previous game where we
make this move e5 and break open the
position that was different because that
was a more defensive plan
here e5 well right now you tend to be
long enough
oh i wanted to play e5 so badly yeah
in that position it makes a lot of sense
as well because
if the bishop's on b7 okay e5 makes
maybe less sense there's rook d8 and the
d5 pawn is being hit
but what we see here is actually kind of
surprising i feel like they don't go
together bishop d7
and a6 i feel like if you're playing
bishop d7 where's a5 where's b4
if you're playing aggressively that's
the way to go but neither side
is trying to push forward at this point
as you just said a6 bishop d7 those
don't go
hand in hand and if you're playing
bishop d4 rookie one all this stuff
don't you usually play e5 so i think
he's now considering it
and there it is you could tell by the
fact that he spent 20 plus seconds and
now he's breaking free and i like
white's position
um so i would have given a real thought
to the move uh
bishop takes e5 uh and followed up with
queen d4
that that puts like a lot of pressure on
g7 also hits
the knights oh wow okay that's just such
a weird move leaving the knight
hanging like that i mean i get that the
the knight is loose but it makes me
think of like knight takes f7 like
what's going on here
knight digit 7 should just be a good
move you win a pawn roberto plays it
and look at lawrence he did not at all
see that move he just shakes his head in
disbelief
and you mentioned tilt starting to feel
like we're getting tilt
yeah this is so uncharacteristic
um what i'm seeing here because this is
just falling apart here this is
completely busted
yeah you just drop a pawn f7 that's such
an important pawn if you drop the h7
pawn
and put a pawn back on f7 your king
feels safe maybe you can fight back in
the game like roberto did when he was
down a pawn
here the king is open there's still
chances for black of course that bishop
on g7 remains a monster
the pawn on d5 is an isolated pawn it's
a pass pawn but if you can attack it
then you may be able to win it so
roberto has his work cut out for him he
is
up a pawn here and he needs to figure
out the right path forward
yeah and i mean trades obviously if uh
if things simplify too much maybe he has
a chance in the end game and
we can sort of say hey that's a more
active king but
it's a long way to go before we get that
and d6 might indicate
ideas like rook e7 getting that pawn
even further up the board
bishop f8 played and man lawrence is
just grasping at straws because he can't
even take this pawn
on d6 yet no you cannot and i would love
to
get my queen to d5 or something like
that but your knights there
and i think that lawrence needs to put
his bishop on c6 and i think he'll make
that move now but the problem with
playing bishop c6 at least
psychologically
is you allow d7 d7 is covered for the
moment
but you need to blockade the piece and
hey he's one move away from playing
knight to d7
the problem with that being where are
the pieces defending your king again
so if you bring your knight to the
center of the board your king is not
very happy no it's a good point because
um i wanted to also give some credit to
roberto for this move rook d1
um there's nothing that blackrook can do
in the e-file the white rook however
supports the pawn
uh ready to push it forward even further
queen f4
is now possible uh going towards the
king side i think that he's doing
very very well here he is and i think he
needs just another
avenue of attack and g4 threatening g5
it's too obvious and you risk your own
king safety
so you need to find a way to make
inroads in another manner i'm looking
to at some point with my knight on e4 so
maybe pawn f3 but that also
has some risk to it because you start
pushing the pawns in front of your king
it feels a little less safe a little bit
loose a little bit loose you know as
soon as you start thinking about
g4 and trying to go g5 taking advantage
of the pin
you just tell yourself ah you know it's
playing g4 that's kind of a weakness and
you think twice about it
and he plays knight d5 he's just saying
i am going for the kill immediately
and the rook is uh immune from capture
the knight is pinned of course and f6
king g8 the rook will just slide back
that's all good and fun the one thing
that i'm looking at
long term is this bishop on g7 and that
pawn on b2
if you don't see that when this knight
moves exactly to d7
and for some reason you forget maybe
that bishop can go ahead and steal that
pawn
and that's why bishop d4 was played yeah
bishop d4 is unfortunately so strong
um this queen queen takes d6 bishop
takes okay so yeah this is just
this should be fine yeah you're trying
to like come up with counter play here
for lawrence you are about even the
clock under 30 seconds it will be a
bullet game
and what you would ideally have is the
bishop one g7 traded for the bishop on
c2
not when and the queen's off the board
because the knight is blockading on a
light square
you don't want to see a light square
bishop come attack your knight later so
he just doesn't have any
guard for his king and i expect that
there will be a checkmate in the near
future the bishop can come to e4
and into d5 if you're not careful oh g4
now just great there's the g4 move
played with confidence and uh
now g6 is weak as soon as h6 happens you
know you you start looking
at the g6 pawn as a potential target
right and
well i don't like bishop before walking
into a pin so rook e2
maybe rookie three but rook d7 down goes
the d6 pawn
wow and you don't take and rook d2
i think black might win this game
believe it or not definitely definitely
okay so rookie six good move hitting the
knight in the a6 and the h6 pawns
you can oh look at that move roberto has
been
so sharp with the pins today that was
just
great awareness and now black can't move
yeah it's just stuck
rook d7 h4 f4
yes we can't go rook d3 the bishop
covers the square so
good on lawrence trying to get those
pawns though but that king might get
mated there might be a mate against the
king
of six somehow yeah it's so hard to to
orchestrate but
you're thinking about it you are and
well here goes the c pawn but take on h6
is the
h p promoting with mate what is
happening here
now there's some knight moves c2 take it
and then take one d5 yeah that was a
blunder
c2 is just not it you know if
wait this is actually a really tricky
move knight b4 maybe okay or take on g5
first maybe and then knight before
you're right
roxy seven king d6 yeah he's just gonna
take it
oh my gosh what the hell is going on
i don't know and there's three pawns
going for two king of four and then king
e3
oh and then you take off seven what is
happening
i don't know okay we're going to see a
draw
oh my god oh my gosh what happened here
we're laughing because we have we can't
wrap our heads around all of these
moves that were played and it wasn't say
things that fast
no oh and who is more upset about that
game
uh that's a good question i think i
think roberto
for sure um i think roberto for sure
just because
he he was winning like even after he
maybe messed things up he still played
so well like
he got that pin in as you mentioned that
was key yeah he's been
very alert for those pins the game where
he went up a piece earlier and then
even lost that game uh he he's been
seeing that very well
and lawrence you could tell during that
game he did not see knight takes up
seven so
tactically it feels like lawrence is not
in his finest form these last bunch of
games
but that is where he really makes his
mark so we'll see how this game goes
it's a caricon
it's a more closed position and that
to my eyes benefits roberto
yeah this is not um something we've seen
before because the last time we saw the
caracon
of course it was that poison pond
variation
right and here black can keep this queen
on b6 play knight d7
at some point consider f6 a thematic
break but this is
roberto style come on lawrence let's go
to the end game buddy
i will outplay you we have all eight
pawns on the board and lawrence is a
fantastic endgame player
it's just not what he enjoys playing so
that's why he dropped his queen back to
d1
yep absolutely queen a6 uh still on a
good diagonal so it's not like black
you know misplaced his pieces to offer
that trade if black ever goes for
c5 knight c6 to put some pressure there
might be time for just knight a3 knight
b5 which is a
really really good square for white
hitting d6 hitting c7 and well
actually c5 has been played and i would
play knight a3 in a heartbeat
and here it comes the knights come right
to b5 and you can technically castle
queen set i would not it
oh obviously i would not advise that but
he says what do you know
i am going to castle and perhaps white
can't actually attack that black king
well there you go castle king b8 i am
not too impressed by this queen on a6 i
feel like you got to get rid of that
knight like knight a7 or something
97 would be good right now and bishop e7
a bit
slow but white can go for f5 you have so
much more space in this position
from lawrence's perspective and so i
would have played f5 and this is why
i would have played f5 first because now
if you play f5 good luck to your king on
g1
maybe it escapes perhaps it's fine but
that's not what you want to
open up the king side when your king is
the only one there
yep so h5 do you play g5 as white here
that's the question because g5 of course
the f5 square is gone but
the g6 pawn is weak and kind of a
decision you have to make if you play g
takes h5 at some point
you have the better structure maybe for
an end game but
we're far from the end game we're very
far from the end game and i did not like
that choice by roberto because this is
thematic
if someone takes on d4 you want a knight
on d4 poking at this e6 pawn so
look at this you trade away black's
defensive knight
and now that knight on b5 you said it's
going to be a pain it remains
so what are you going to do about that
night long term
very strong piece i mean there's
definitely just gh5 rook h5 to be
considered here i
i would probably play that honestly
because the queen
is so offside on a6 that i say look you
can play rook
d to g8 check i'll go king f3 or king f2
with my rook on h5 and i i think i'm
covering everything there
yeah it's one of those decisions where
as a commentator i completely agree with
you and i know if i was playing the game
i would never do it
you know it's too risky can't go for
that but you're right there was a
possibility
and here i don't like the fact that the
pawn is on b4 because your c3
pawn looks a bit in trouble the rook c8
rooks c4
i'm gonna use the square in front of
that backward pawn that's often what you
want to do
so i do think that black has plenty of
play against this king
because it's on g2 so now if you take on
h5 roberto of course will take back
open up a check that king is in trouble
yeah and
he might be relying on like rook c896
stopping
uh rook c4 but it just opens up the
floodgates for
uh queen e2 check and everything
everything falls like as soon as that
knight moves
uh it's it's big trouble but queen b6 is
like totally different
than i thought not what i expected at
all this is falling apart for black
yeah the e6 pawn is hanging knight c6
check is 14 and now rook b1
should just win all right a5 first
one of these moves just to go for it and
so
b6 for sure or sorry knight c5
rook b5 rook c8 could happen
wow that's like barely hanging on there
but he's going to rely on b6 and
try to keep that pawn stuck the problem
is normally you plant your king in front
of pawn it would be an umbrella pawn
your king feels safe with the pawn
on v6 but not when the knight's coming
right back to b5 and into the d6 square
knight b5 d6 is nasty um i would almost
start with that yeah i
i would feel like starting with that
makes sense
although can i take an a5 now because if
you go knight d6 check my king is a c6
it looks scary but you take my rook i
take yours that's a fair trade
yeah that's pretty that's pretty nice
knight d6 king c6
oh and i read lawrence's lips there
he was not happy that b takes a5 he
missed it he didn't see it coming
no doubt he was just noticing that it
uh completely foiled his plans and if
you go rook b7 or something aggressive
rook b8
the knights guarding that square it's
super frustrating and this is what's
happening right
we're going to trade rooks the black
knight can go to c5 where it covers the
e6 pawn and the a6 square
then that pawn on c3 is a bit loose so i
think that
roberto has the upper hand maybe we run
the
the king here is that the way to go
looks pretty good but perhaps we're back
to saying i'm too quick myself i'm going
to win your c3 pawn
and my d-pawn can start running or is
that
good enough though
as as white you play rook a6
check and you don't calculate rook takes
b6
like if you can't trade the rooks i
don't agree with the check because it
feels like i'm sort of handing the move
over
but uh white's playing rook c8 roxie you
win a piece
i was about to say brook seed is mate
but now worksafe's no longer meet but
the knight can't be defended
lawrence lawrence is so animated
whenever whenever that happens i just
look over at the cam
yeah he's shaking his hand he's like i
got the hot hand now but
that was the first time i saw roberto
react and he was
look at him he's still shaking his head
he can't get over the fact that he just
blundered that completely
because there's been so many examples of
that in this match
piece up totally winning and it just
flips in a single move
that's crazy he's gonna resign that and
roberto and look at lawrence triumphant
there
but roberto did not play his best game i
think we should be clear about that he
is a fantastic player but he just didn't
find
the way to coordinate his pieces well
and he made some decisions that
end up being very questionable like you
know taking on d4 at first
and then giving lawrence free attack on
the queen side
but then he found the right moves in
critical moments he took on a5
he got his king to c6 rook to b8 and he
was turning it around and so you kind of
forget
about how bad your position was and you
remember wait i was playing for the win
and then two moves later i lose a piece
no that's a that's a good point but i
think overall
he would be the first to agree with you
that that wasn't start to finish
the best game that he's put together
this match um and
lawrence is i mean he's taking his
chances man when he gets
an opportunity he takes it um he's not
really missing these these free pieces
it's more that like
sometimes we get positions where he wins
that piece and then
can't convert after that but luckily in
this game or that last game we just saw
it was
too easy after winning that piece so he
does take that point and take the lead
in this match again five to four and a
good start to the three-minute section
for lawrence and this has been a very
high level match i'm impressed by
both players to this point and lawrence
is a point ahead he's in great shape
and right now in this position that
knight on h3 it's such a
thorn in white side it looks trapped it
has nowhere to go but you can't attack
it and the bishop on c8
it returns to a starting square it
defends it and you have to watch out for
tactics involving pawn f5
temporarily giving up that knight for
the attack i like lawrence's position
bishop g4 to start with might be
first and then f5 yeah bishop g4 looks
like a
nice move because you can almost ignore
it like bishop
g4 b4 it's like okay f5 maybe like
you can almost just run brent forward
with the pawn because that pin to the
queen is so nasty and none of white's
pieces
can really come to its defense yeah and
lauren says
queen d7 he's thinking for the checkmate
he's like well i'll lead with my queen
and there could be some knight f4 check
sacrifices with
you know queen h3 to follow actually can
he get away with that
i was just saying h3 and bishop g4 yeah
i was sort of saying it in broad terms
but now that i'm looking at it
that could work that would be nuts
and there he goes so queen h3 king
h1 bishop g4 and then if rookie three
you just take back on f4
is what i was thinking and you're
hitting everything hitting the knight
hitting yeah
literally every piece i don't think this
changes anything you can still go queen
h3 it's the same line
although now you can move your knight so
knight h4
i'm not sure if that's a good move but
at least you stop checkmate bishop g4
you could put pawn f3 to
block the bishop so there's a little
more flexibility in the approach you can
also take on a four with the bishop on
uh c1 i don't really like that because e
takes f4 and your
knight and c3 hangs this is a wild
position
this is spicy already i think lawrence
is if this
works like if you can play knight f4 and
it can't be taken you're already on the
right path
that's right and you just can't get
complacent right you
had a good tactic but you need to keep
it up and for roberto he's down
over half a minute on the clock he's
trying to figure out can i take this
knight into four do i just have to leave
it there
should i play knight h4 that also looks
wrong because even a move like bishop f6
to just
try to take that knight looks pretty
good for black and he plays rook g1 when
it's all said and done but
bishop g4 it looks menacing but maybe
that knight nc5 can be captured
come on what's going on here man well
what's going on is you just came up with
a cantism
ricci won and it's all said and done
that's
that's one right there we gotta we gotta
remember that one
rook g1 it's all said and done uh bishop
g4 i
what's going on i literally have no idea
but i love it for black
i'm here for it this this is exactly
what lawrence wants from
every game if he could if he could have
it he would play this way every single
game and
i love him got f4 coming he's got a
knight that's hanging
on the board but he plays bishop g4 and
he says i don't care at all
so if you take the knight queen h5
you're going to lose your knight in f3
can you just sacrifice your queen not my
queen but i move like knight h4 there or
something so
take my queen i'll take back with my
bishop your queen on h5 is in trouble
you're not in the f4 is under attack
i'm threatening you on the queen side
with my pawn i think that might be the
practical choice necessary but you have
28 seconds counting down now for roberto
you just need to move
and i'm sacking my queen for sure now
yeah it's crazy at this point you have
to come to that conclusion that it's a
good idea
and that's so hard to do it really is um
taking this knight and then giving up
the queen
i think you win this night as well so
you do get your three pieces but
if he doesn't find that i think he's
just lost he's got six seconds and
the clock is ticking okay he does take
it so that he makes the good decision
but he doesn't have enough time left to
keep on playing
wow all right he does it he's a very
good bullet player though
if he doesn't lose his game ahmad that's
insane
it's absolutely insane but two minutes
to four seconds this position is harder
to play for black
from oh there's nothing left to play
because it's
okay do you see roberto
he is so angry and i don't even think he
looked at his clock really
and lawrence was like yes i did it
i'm he was so proud of himself there but
honestly from a chess
perspective just that final position was
so
immensely complicated i think it was
easier to play for white
if roberto was able to get his move off
yeah
no this this is like uh the the type of
chess that we're seeing right here
you've said it and i'll just echo it
again it's really high level
like both guys are playing really well
the games like there's blunders here and
there but this is speed chess you're
gonna have pieces hanging from time to
time
you're gonna have blenders but we
haven't seen egregious egregious
mistakes yet
um so i just think we've been treated to
a very high level match and lawrence
the underdog surely coming into this is
performing he's up two games right now
setting us up for a potential lead from
him going into the bullet and a very
exciting finish robert
and we have seen swings before lawrence
he was jetting out to a two-game lead in
the longest time patrol roberto stormed
right back to tie it
so right now we're going to break
lawrence trent is
really thrilled about his performance
he's up two games but roberto molina
will try to bounce back
remain seated we'll be back shortly
so
and we return lawrence trent with a six
to four lead over
roberto molina amman lawrence has been
mighty impressive it's been shaky for
both players at times but ultimately
this has been a well fought match
and i think lawrence has earned his lead
thus far
absolutely and uh not only has this been
a great
match entertaining from both sides
there's been their fair share of
blunders
there's been a very high level match and
when you have these high level matches
someone has the lead it's fully deserved
like when people are flagging in this
time control they have a tough
position like in this match we haven't
seen people uh just
running out of time with a completely
winning position which we've seen in so
many speedchest matches
what we're seeing here are players
putting their opponents in tough
positions
and then the clock running out so all
the the points that the players have
feel totally deserved and we have six
four right now for lawrence trent we're
at the halfway point
of the three minute portion and uh is
your feeling that lawrence has to keep
up a lead
going into the bullet or i mean if it's
a tied match it could be anyone's uh
game in the bullet portion
yeah at first i would have said that he
would definitely need a lead but the way
he's been playing and the time travel
that roberto's been getting into
i think lawrence is better prepared and
he understands the foundations of these
positions very well
right and back to this um same line that
they they played last time and now
allowing
a5 is roberto so last time he played a5
and this was one of the games robert
that you were mentioning
uh roberto might be the first to admit
that wasn't his best game
uh in the format yeah it really wasn't
and
it went from locked up to tactical all
of a sudden and i don't think he made
the switch that well
and look at lawrence he says i'm going
to take on d3 with my pawn
my pawn structure is not very good but
what are you going to do for black how
are you going to break in this position
oh guess what you're going to play c5
well that undoubles my pawns in the
process so lawrence i don't
like the look of his pawn structure but
it is his type of position
even if it's not mine yeah and when i
see
f4 i was going to say the first move i
would play
is h5 and the reason that f5 is being
played
is i mean if you just look at the
position with the move like g5 in there
black goes g6 locks everything up all
light square pawns
dark square bishops on the board would
be really good for black so
uh he's played f5 and i think this is
the perfect
reaction whether it's the best move or
not you can't allow the thing
the position to get locked up and he
takes on f5 so
lawrence i think he's gonna take back
there he goes
and this looks really promising for
white all of a sudden but roberto is
just saying hey i don't care i'm gonna
castle
queen side get out of trouble this this
looks sketchy to me
very sketchy bishop f4 um
okay so pawn being hit on f5 and you
can't protect it
yeah i know you like queen f3 it's kind
of crazy
wait did he like wait for knight f3 so
that he could play 97 was he being a
trickster there
it looked like it i mean 97 was played
as a follow-up to pawn takes pawn which
doesn't seem really to do anything and
then knight f3 just kind of
nonchalant and then 97 it's like wait a
minute now he has to play
well f6 and e6 neither move looks really
good
no they don't and the pawn structure
wasn't good for white to start with the
doubled
pawns in the d-file here and now f5 is
falling so is there a way to
quickly say castle get your rook to the
open f file and attack or is it just a
pawn that you're being
you're handing over to your opponent it
looks
like a pawn you're handing over i i
don't really see a way out i mean queen
g3 is available
um taking a knight f6 this
definitely doesn't smell right but you
know lawrence is gonna be one to
complicate things
instead of just handing over a pawn even
if handing over the pawn
is maybe the smarter or more objective
choice
and it is complicated indeed because
queen g3 check can be played roberto
refrains from doing so he can do so
again now but he chooses not to so
he just says i'm going to get your pawn
e6 i can play queen d6
go after that pawn i can go knight f5
bring my knight to g3
i can castle queen side and you don't
really have an attack
so somehow this has turned in roberto's
favor
very quickly yeah the the thing about
the position here
for um lawrence is that
his issues are on the light squares like
knight f5 and hg4 are both going to
happen
there might be a long castle but to be
honest even short castling makes
probably even more sense for a rubric if
he can get short castles here safely
knight f5 bishop e7 or d6 there's still
queen g3 looming now there's knight g3
this is just looking better and better
um for black because the pawns on the
queen side look how they're fixed
nothing can move here and this pawn
chain for black is really really solid
and rook g1 played which means that
lawrence is going to castle queenside
because
he can't castle kingston anymore so i i
think bishop d6 just developed
castle kingside as you said and
roberto's king is safe there because
of the light square diamonds is lawrence
going to be able to sacrifice
like a rook on g4 and exchange there and
try to get an attack
i don't see it happening though no this
looks like it could be one of the
cleaner games we've seen from this match
where it almost looks one-sided from the
start
there was that one game lawrence had
which looked like pure tilt
near the end of the five minute where it
was like just honestly a very short game
and roberto cleaned that one up but this
looks like uh you know
a throwback to that because kingside
castle
rook a to e8 if white ever castles
queenside there's queen takes a5 as well
this is just looking crushing and this
is the
downside of lawrence's style we've seen
the benefits he's played some
marvelous attacking chess but he is he
he tunnels he's like
i want to attack and checkmate my
opponent and this happens with people of
various styles sometimes if you're too
positional you may miss tactics and then
get squeezed down because you give up
all the space so
it is a stylistic decision and i think
that it is backfiring in this game
overall it's worked out right now as you
said rook a to e8
rook f6 just win this pawn on e6 and
once the position opens up
it's white's king that's just a big
danger
and it's kind of a funny move if king c2
i was really looking at knight h2
as like a a funny way that i think it
seems to me like it just
wins actually yes you're trying to
distract that knight from the d4 pawn
and
well that's why knight g5 doesn't work
because knight g5 would defend the e6
pawn but you're dropping d4 then the
knight hits the queen goes knight p3
check
everything is falling apart and the
reason that lawrence played king c1 is
he didn't want to put his king and queen
on a square knight d4 what happened so
that he could play
knight g5 let's be clear knight d4
threatens knight b3
it wins a pawn in the center i mean
knight f2
hits the d3 pawn and the queen it does
allow queen takes h5
so i certainly wouldn't uh wouldn't
consider it but
just knight takes e6 he's just going so
solid so
so comfortable here roberto's gonna take
this game it's like minus six in this
position
robert two extra pawns but the it's
overwhelming and rook a4
is a good move when you think that that
rook was doing nothing maybe there will
be a sacrifice on g4
but that seems like way too little way
too late and black can play rook f2 here
bishop f4 to follow just taking over the
board
okay well is he gonna sacrifice here i
feel like it's almost
necessary um i don't think it's good
he's gonna take with the queen bishop f4
looks like a strong response looking for
a queen trade
again there's little that white can do
your your attack whatever you think your
attack's going to be
it doesn't happen nearly quickly but i
didn't like queen of seven
invited the pawn to g6 and queen h5 is
next
for the time as well let's not forget
about the clock
guys 10 seconds ticking down here and
lawrence is getting some of his attack
going and look at that move queen to g7
hitting the rook hitting the bishop
where would he even go here seven
seconds queen if it might be the only
move hard move the fight look he just
dropped the bishop also queen e6 check
and then try to get the rook to the h
file white is better
that's better this is ridiculous wow
and we were just praising roberto for
playing like a pristine game
and now he's much worse he's trying to
somehow hold
take on g6 okay the worst of your
problems will be behind you once you
take on g6 but now that a5 pawn
which is weak the whole game is going to
queen that a pawn is a big problem and
queen h6 is crushing
that looks like a great move as well
right
knight f6 check where's that king going
oh my gosh where's the discover check
what where do we go what wait that's 88
that seems just wrong okay but he has
knight d6
barely holy things on here no knight c
doesn't work because
their king would be in check it's like a
nice fork tactic that back everyone has
three seconds in this game this is just
wild the g pawn runs
okay rookie to check the king goes d3
you drop b2 so g4
and g3 keep it going the bishop covers
g1 that's important to remember but the
bishop does not match a8 i know
it may oh okay this is getting
increasingly relevant you know oh my
goodness
a7 but white's doing well here yeah
should just be totally winning
knight takes b5 and then bishop a3 oh my
god one time
oh lords freaked out oh my god
it's totally winning oh my gosh
lawrence just freaked out and
uh my portuguese is not good enough to
to know what
roberto molina just muttered under his
breath there but
i'm sure it was a fine compliment
towards his opponent
yes and uh you lucky fill in the blank
yeah himself
wow what a reaction what an end to that
game
that it just feels like people are are
playing so well
these matches are are flipping around
back and forth
what we've actually seen being the
weakness of these players it seems like
converting advantages
that that's the story of this match so
far and they just
lose sight of their clocks we saw
roberto in the game before the break
he sacrificed his queen but they just
lost some time and he spent so much time
calculating it that he had no time
remaining so both players
have been finding great ideas to survive
the defensive resourcefulness
has been amazing with little time in the
clock but yet
the conversion part that's been a
failure yeah for both of them
yep and we talked about trading pieces
here's one of those games
everything is gone and that's almost
like i feel like it's almost both
players
just relaxing a little bit that's an
incredibly adrenaline-filled match
and now we just get the guys okay let's
just trade let's just have one of these
games it should be a dead draw
but uh roberto controls the only open
file on the board
and if i had to pick a color i'd
probably take white
oh for sure and it's one of these
situations where you're like
oh my gosh i know i need to draw this
game i should draw but then i make
one inaccuracy and i'm on the defensive
for the rest of the game for example
like if queen d6 happens and black is
forced to trade there
that is zero fun for you and the king
gets in and
white's piece is just more active so i
think that what
lords has done is the right thing he was
trying to create some inroads in the
queen side
and now his queen remains active and his
rook is also free to join the party in a
second
yeah this is nice this is nice um i
would take that
a3 is something you give consideration
to but not really when b4 is on the
table
right and i would consider queen d4 for
black like let you took over the d
file first i'm going to take it back now
and if you take me i have a pass pawn
in the center so instead queen b4 makes
perfect sense as well
i feel like both sides are just looking
at this position
knowing that it should be equal with
best play and
coming up with a real plan is not easy
so h4
why not doesn't probably see h5
for the same reason why not yeah i don't
have an answer well
okay now white can consider h5 and the
point is to get
h6 and there it goes yeah this feels
like the first
substantial mistake i would say it's not
that it's losing for black it's nothing
that drastic but if you if you play h6
you're just
tying black down to the defensive
yep so brook d4 is fantastic by lawrence
i would have played queen e3 before the
rook
got to the d-file you want to support
this h-pawn
that's going to tie the king down and
just you know be a nuisance basically
later in the game
if this gets taken he wants to say look
i got rook b8 h6 and there's just going
to be some sort of meeting net ideas
in the position at all times that's
right and look at that pawn h6
how does black accurately fend off most
of the pressure it's not that black is
going to check for rook a1 threatens
checkmate
i don't think you can actually trade
rooks the resulting position looks very
bad
for uh for black i think he might be
going to
but i'm not sure that it's so good he
might be underestimating well with rook
a8 coming
you might have to play rook d1 and maybe
there's just
trade on d1 and then black queen goes to
c2 just to i that e4 pawn but the issue
remains
that at some moment bl white could just
give up some pawns and go checkmate so
queen d8
give up the b4 pawn queen vertex before
there's even queen d2 or queen g5 is an
idea
so two iii takes ticket exactly game
over and that's just a
terrible blunder the game's over and
just resigned
and well not on this game over lawrence
on camera was over he just
went away he is really angry at this
point and roberto
two straight games he has won on a
blunder but i will give
full credit to roberto his strategy in
that game was
perfect he said there will be zero
tactics available to you
we're playing a positional game i have
the open file first i pushed my h-pawn
and lawrence just didn't react in the
best manner yeah and to me it's so
strange in those symmetrical positions
when someone plays h4 like you just play
h5 don't even think about it i mentioned
like
yeah just play h5 because why not but
that's the structure you want
letting white play h5 i know you were
mentioning oh this is kind of a mistake
but it's hard to call that a big blunder
when we're commentating because i mean
okay allowing h5 isn't a big deal but
that was the difference that was the
game it gave white a plan
and before that point they were just
kind of hey let's move here i'll move
there
so what but you're right that he gave
what a clear plan and then
lawrence of queen d8 to stop the queen
infiltrating on the dark squares and
then
he blended his rook the next move so
that was a tough go of things for
lawrence right now he's the better pawn
structure
black's pawns are split on the queen
side a5 and c6 pod's best friend being
another pawn you would like to protect
in that manner however
black gets quick activity thanks to this
d5 square the semi-open b-file
with a rook b8 could be a nice thing the
b4 square bishop coming to c5 i see
the pieces coming alive right now for
black
and i'm actually starting to appreciate
roberto's position more and more
yeah although i like what lawrence has
done i think preemptively g3 to cut
knight f4
knight on e3 bishop d2 covering all the
squares the knight might want to move to
so we'll see things like king e2 uh rook
h to c1 or rook a to c1
and i think lawrence is probably
decently happy here he has something to
play for and now he's hinting maybe he
wants to play knight to c4
and wow king d7 now that is a move that
i like but at first i wouldn't even
considered it but look at this the d5
knight covers the b6 square no check for
you there he can now bring his rook from
h8 there it goes very quickly to b8
and the king is perfect on d7 it will
never be attacked
the pawn c6 is defended because of that
king so i like what roberto has done but
now that we're here
come on what's the plan for either side
yeah i mean white has
i think a few moves uh left in the tank
like maybe rook to c1 or d1 from the h
file
there's f4 that you know white always
has in his mind to
fully connect that pawn chain um
a3 is something i would consider as
white but i think for now i'd probably
leave it as it is
just on a2 so if a3 happens by black i
have the option to go b3 or take that
a3 just gives up the b3 square and i'm
just not sure about that one i
don't like it so i think i'd bring the
rook in maybe try to connect the pawns
and bishop to b4 is looking to say hey i
want to trade bishops
and then play knight b4 and that looks
like a good plan
absolutely so it was interesting that
this game is
might come down to the move a3 for
either side whether it's good or not
remains to be seen but there
is that idea for both going forward so
h6 by roberto just playing slowly that
pawn
was under attack it should not have been
captured don't go full fisher
your bishop would have been caught over
there but you just don't even want to
worry about that
and so he plays h6 now what is white's
move here
how do you improve your position rook d
to c2 trying to double in the file the
knight to before that doesn't look good
so he plays h4
and maybe he'll play f4 king f3
g4 and try to use the king side push
but does that really get you anywhere um
i don't know if black has any threats
upcoming i mean the idea of like rook b7
taking and taking on b2 definitely comes
to mind but you can take with
the rook potentially and think about
this pawn there's all sorts of
long-term considerations white on the
other hand h5
followed by f4 doesn't seem like a bad
way to fix those pawns on the king's
side
that's very true and it said lawrence
goes knight d6
he trades off the bishops the f7 pawn
isn't an attack and or bert says
it may be under attack but your knight
isn't well defended i'm just gonna play
f6 and
if f4 will black trade on e5 and bring
the rook from b8 to f8
i guess that would have been a thought
and king of the hill
what a move game over right king of the
hill it's it's uh
it's a winner lawrence is uh gonna get
out of his chair and start screaming
that the the game isn't over yet this is
some
issue and you can play rook a7 to b7
here because the knight on d6 can't
capture the rook
without dropping the rook on c4 so if
you want to keep this tension alive
rook a to b7 feels like a good move
look at him he is reading your mind
right now rook b7
and uh b2 is hanging here as well
um because i think again if you take
that there's rook takes
on d2 so actually does come packed with
a threat
and if you take right you give up some
ground there and the e5 pawn could drop
and the d6 knight
loses its stronghold so right now it's a
tough moment for lawrence and he
is down by nearly 20 seconds at this
point
so he needs to start moving more quickly
it's just a tough position to figure out
yeah and what what a match we've had
it's been you know
different leaders at different points um
i'm trying to think back to the
beginning of this
this match but uh it feels like lawrence
has been the only one with a lead so far
is that is that right i don't think
roberto has been ahead so far
he's never been tied but i don't think
he's been ahead that's correct he lost
game one he won game two and then lauren
started
with a winning streak he came back but
he has never taken the lead
he's on verge right now this is
dangerous territory for lawrence we've
seen him react to blunders to losing on
time all this stuff
if he goes down the match that could
spell full disaster and he can go on
tilt but look at this it's locked up
over here
i'm not sure who i prefer this position
for
because the knight on d5 is really
strong but so it's that knight on d6
yeah and i don't know about like my
instinct would be king d4 maybe there
was something wrong with king d4 but
i would have played that instead of king
f3 yeah maybe there was
word a timely g5 it doesn't well you can
consider g5
yeah even here it's has a lot of risk
though
yeah g5 the idea being um if you play f
takes and h5 that might be the issue
and i guess there's this and well if you
go and distract yourself on the king
side
can i wait and then go rook h4 like if
you go rook takes g5 can you say rook h4
and win your a4 pawn
right wow the cross board gameplay there
rook h4 going all the way back
over to collect that a pawn and then
going rook a7 check and black of course
wants to say look i'm bringing the king
up the board there's no way i'm going
backwards the king d8 i think you have
to do something on the queen side play
for your past c pawn so
a3 giving up a pawn or in this case yeah
before to start winning some of these
queen side pawns
you need to try to promote that c part
e5 is falling so knight f7
an ugly move but perhaps force and look
at however
what do you do though yeah this is
looking very difficult knight takes e5
check maybe we'll get a liquidation
and you just play rook a8 but king of
six don't take the pawn right away your
rook is defending yeah
oh i would have gotten king f6 okay
still i probably prefer black though
um e5 e4 just by a small amount though
smaller yes black is more active the
rook on g4 cuts the king off he can play
e4
check the king goes back to f2 and there
goes black's king
but i think lawrence has enough to hold
this position the king
definitely should and he is going to be
livid if he does not hold this because
that that's just the wrong wrong energy
to have
you need to hold this draw and i think
he
oh that wasn't maybe the best rookies b3
oh my goodness
and look at lawrence look at lawrence he
cannot believe it he's beside himself
it's just not acceptable he he had to
draw technique it was just check check
check check back and forth
and grook d3 don't i don't even get away
with that
so he goes king c4 that's smart and now
king is just gonna collect the pawn
yes oh that's a good move though that's
a really good movie
that's a really really good move but
unfortunately roberto knew how to meet
it just pushed that
one yeah yeah
wow this is going to be a loss for for
lawrence i think
at this point there's just too much time
uh and he's gonna get rook e1
check oh okay would have maybe checked
but
same ideas yeah you cut the king off and
now you build the bridge so this
actually is instructive for most of our
viewers and how to win
this end game and look at the rookton d5
don't trade the rooks just yet the king
would be allowed back in front of the
pawn
you just wait you bring your king in and
then you promote so win
for roberto and we've been saying that a
lot because
i think it's been well at least three in
a row
um if not more but yeah i think three
wins in a row for
uh roberto molino from brazil this is
this is crazy right now lawrence is just
falling apart and he's doing it at the
worst time this might be the last three
minute game
imagine that this trends even more and
more in roberto's direction it's gonna
be
eight to six and with with just a
collapse in the three-minute portion
that's not what you need going into
bullet no it is not
and i will say that this type of
position it could get quite tactical so
i like how the opening has gone for
lawrence
but i wonder amon was lawrence like
weirdly playing for a win there
why would he bring his rook to c4 in the
play pushes apon what was
that about i don't i don't know i think
i think he was
not playing for a win um i think it was
just
you know he saw the opportunity rook c4
good square for the rook when the king
was there
and just sort of overestimated the
the idea that you don't have to do
anything when you're looking for a draw
or you're looking to hold a position
sometimes doing nothing is the best
thing to do and he tried to do
something and he didn't have anything to
do and he just saw the apon he's like
well there's something i can throw up
the board
so i think it was just a product of
trying to do something when
nothing was necessary to do at all i
think that's
right that's what happened and for
lawrence he probably was getting nervous
at that point and he pushed his pawn
thinking that he would lose it
regardless but that dropped the b3 pawn
which was an issue and now in this game
well roberto
i i like how the opening went for
lawrence but i don't like this position
for him because if we look at the
quality of pieces
and what squares can be hours from
taking
the light squares all over here are
going to be
under white's control and he can take
here play pawn to b5
knight into d5 and what is black going
to do about any of this rook to a1
yeah at this point i think this is
exactly where roberto wants to be
comfortable playing a positional game uh
there's
not a lot of dangerous tactics i mean
there's still pieces on the board but
it's really reminiscent
of that earlier game that they played i
think it was the second game of the
match
where lawrence had these exact two
pieces on the board a knight and a dark
square bishop and we were
it was just a you know race can he
activate them
make some threats or is this going to be
an end game and here c5 looks very
powerful you can never take with the
d-pawn because the rook will land on d7
winning your queen and he makes a
retreating move which is good because
they attacked the rook he just repeated
once
that's a nice thing now bishop takes e5
as a threat if lawrence didn't see it
that's a grip a great point it's c5 so
the thing is i think he went back to e4
because he noticed c5
after he did it he was like oh let's go
back see if he goes back to a2
now he plays c5 anyway and i actually
like this
decision from lawrence even though his
position is bad that he can't just get
squeezed like this
he needs to do something with his pieces
and sometimes you drop a pawn but the
rest of your pieces feel happier
here c5 is hanging e5 is hanging but
look at this move rook a2
it's much more lawrence's style to play
in this manner he defends
with an offense rather than just sitting
passively yep
and i'm wondering what the follow-up is
if you move that queen too far away from
that e pawn bishop takes e3 bishop d4
happens and that's that's over right
there and e4
the reason that that's kind of an
annoying move um for white
actually is that the bishop controls d2
so it's like it's kind of a hard
pin to get out of or it's just a little
bit awkward here uh for roberto
right and if you go rook takes c5 there
could be queen b6 if you're unaware of
this
the bishop is hanging but rook d7 check
will win the queen that is a
brilliant move by roberto here is rook
a6 or queen a6
needed here oh both of those moves do
not look fun though
bishop takes e5 maybe just grab the
central pawn
how else do we do it i don't know um
yeah rook d7 looks pretty strong just to
trade queens he might prefer that
because the queen's good off the board
that is bishop looks solid that's a very
roberto decision to make but right now
he takes on e5 he he has the sense that
this match
is really turning in his favor and if he
can win this game the final game
of the three plus one time drill he'll
exit with a two-game lead
and he came into it you know earlier in
the match with a two-game deficit so
yeah what a comeback it's been by
roberto
yeah and and this three minute portion
it says three and a half to two and a
half i'm pretty sure
that it started with like a draw and
then it was two wins from lawrence
so he has actually won four straight
games i think
it might even be or something to that
effect the point is he's made an insane
comeback in this three minute portion
and
if you can cap it off with a win here
then you go into the break all that
confidence you're up two games then the
bullet happens where
he probably thinks he should be the
favorite lawrence needs to tie this
match right now
because he has been letting his emotions
get the better of him
and i think he needs a win to get back
on track
i would agree and well as king is on h6
so i don't know about winning this game
but roberto and lawrence about even in
the clock white's position is better
it's even material both sides have
two rooks queen bishop and four pawns
but there's a king on h6 out in the open
the c5 pawn the
c7 pawn both are weak and queen b2 i
think just wins in the spot
hitting the g7 square and the rook on a3
wow queen b2 is a sneaky sneaky bishop
g7 check
um i guess there's rook a8 there
but it still looks like a really good
move
and maybe it didn't win but i looked at
it i was like well the g7 score is where
i want to go
and it looks like it should have been
winning
this still so yeah this looks fantastic
um still hope for lawrence like i would
maybe go like bishop
e7 almost bishop f6 i think if you trade
the
the bishops it's very very scary because
the pieces just pile up on the
on the c pawn white needs to also play
like something like h3
um just to get an escape score for that
king and what about this trade because
this could turn into a position where
let's say one more piece gets traded
after the bishops
let's say the queens get traded and now
europe would probably be up upon
regardless these one of the c pawns will
drop
but is that enough material to win
that's difficult
holy that's a good one rook d8 because
if you get a queen end game
the king is tucked on each one and you
have a pass pawn that is a lot more
mobile
than that e pawn the black king can
catch uh white's epon a lot easier
than white's king can catch the c pawn
with the help of the queen and he could
have traded rooks and taken the c5 pawn
but the same situation would have
existed where black would have been down
to palm but the c pawn with the queen
would have started
rolling up the board so here oh there's
no way white can win this game the king
is stuck in the corner
and in fact lawrence might be able to
somehow take this over if queen takes c5
is played
rook do you want check so do not take
that pawn if i'm lawrence yeah give up
that pawn
it's almost too obvious right
you shouldn't have attacked the queen
lauren you should have left it just
randomly over there
but c4 d2 c or rook d2 or c4
keep pushing those pieces and go after
white's king the problem is black's king
is also very exposed so there will
likely be
f4 and rook c5 oh f4 check was winning
but queen of fate's also good
so what's what's the idea oh he's just
setting that
up and queen quincy five you in the rook
queens if i wins the rule
he sees it lawrence is gonna is gonna
exit this three-minute portion
in terrible shape did you see that
he looked scared like he didn't even
look surprised
he looked like he was frightened by what
just happened and he
is distraught he is devastated
look at the guy he's not even on camera
anymore
not even he's not even there it's the
the headless horseman
wow wow
borderline's speechless but that game
seems like if we just look at the
conclusion there lawrence's reaction you
know the blunder all this stuff
but roberto kept up the pressure
throughout the game
and he had a beautiful game towards the
end there he went astray
lawrence was able to actually have a
better position more active position
but the whole game roberto put him under
pressure and then
in the end he spotted tactics when
lawrence tried too hard to win
yeah and that's set up with queen f8
rook f1
just to play the pawn to f4 that was
beautiful and lawrence
just just collapsed in that three-minute
portion i mean he looked frightened as
you said like
literally frightened to see queen c5 on
the board that's like
you know finding something weird out
from ancestry.com reports
he looked surprised and we are surprised
as well
that the leader of this match is
actually roberto going into the bullet
uh i mean if there's anything uh a
tilted player wants to play
robert it's bullet chess so i'm excited
for the the next portion
so my everybody will come back shortly
with the bullet portion of this match
it is a two game lead for roberto molina
but lawrence trent has that aggressive
style to mount a comeback
stay tuned we'll be back shortly
we have yet to determine who will move
on to the semi-finals but we know that
it will be
a tough battle between the winner of
this match
and the winner of lars oscar hogg and
teddy coleman
aman what do you think what do you think
about this bracket
what do we have in store for the
remaining matches
well it's a really uh interesting
question because the
the first round has finally been
concluded this is the first
look at these next set of matches and
lars oscar and teddy coleman
the thing about teddy is you know you
just can't bet against teddy such a
solid player he
is always always in the match no matter
if his opponent
is much higher rated than him or not
lars of course
going in is obviously the favorite but
um i don't think that that match is said
and done because lars did look a little
bit shaky
however showed up in the bullet portion
whereas roberto and lawrence were
waiting to be decided but
you know the winner of this match is
going to face the winner of lars
and teddy so i think if we get a
match-up like for example
teddy and uh roberto it could just be
the most solid match we've ever seen and
if we get
lars against lawrence it could just be
tactics every single game so
i'm excited for that no matter what for
sure and i know that many people out
there
are especially excited for the matchup
between levy rosman that is gotham chess
and eric rosen
eric did win his game his match excuse
me yesterday against sagrasha
so that will be a fun one indeed between
two of the best content creators out
there
and two friendly personalities that
people i'm sure will have
a very big rooting interest in yeah
they'll definitely see some uh
some firm opinions uh about who they
want to win
that match but for now we're getting
into the bullet section
robert of this match and i i mentioned
and i i meant it that
you know what does a tilted player want
to do he wants to play bullet chest do
you think this is going to bode well for
him here robert
look at this 92 e5 i think he has
chances but look at roberto's bullet
rating
that is not a mistake that is 28.59
so lawrence has his work cut out for him
but i like the opening choice even if i
don't understand a single move play this
far
yeah no i mean uh basically
what we see here is lawrence has uh you
know a heavyweight
uh to take care of a 28 59
in bullet roberto is no joke and uh this
everything we've seen in the match so
far might just get accentuated
in bullets so i think we're either
getting a very close match or we could
just see a blowout from roberto
yeah i think it's a fair call and right
now the position somehow looks
relatively normal
after the very strange start white can
put the pawn on d4
if he so chooses put a knight on e5 we
have an iqp
position but i like that lawrence is
refraining from pushing the d-pawn the
bishop on b2 is much stronger
without that pawn in its path yeah
knight c4 just hitting that bishop
but we do see the night getting into e5
the bishop will return
at some point to to b2 and there it goes
rookie one and
those bishops eyeballing the king side i
think this is a position that lawrence
is probably happy to get
you know might not be the most sound but
hey everything's pointing in one
direction you know where the action is
well if there's is there ever a time for
harry styles reference it was after you
just said one direction but right now
i'm looking at the king side as well g6
is a very scary move to have to play for
black because that fish won't be two
now it has the full length of diagonal
and i'm looking at tactics right if you
remove the knight from e5
knight g4 right just when they get on
the spot
that has to be e5 i was gonna say it's
the only try knight takes f6 queen takes
f6 and run the king
that's all we got can i just take on e5
instead like i just go knight back and
take on e5
he doesn't he goes to the h7 pawn okay
probably not the
most uh forcing decision but um d4
if he controls that e7 square keep in
mind guys queen h8 is
check made in one that's true so
actually is
lawrence winning another pawn it looks
like it to me and if he gets a second
pawn
then he's well on his way here and yes
roberto's down 15 seconds
yep and if that bishop
ever leaves that diagonal keep in mind
bishop a3 is also going to lead to well
maybe maybe more but rook takes e5 queen
takes e5 is a background check oh
my god oh that's a commentator's current
oh and he missed it
i feel so much better i was about to
feel horrible that i just
jinxed him and
how did both players miss that i thought
at least someone was
was setting that up wow and the game
continues and lawrence is up on the
clock he's up two pawns he can push his
pawn to d5 so king g7 is not a
possibility here there's no
second rank infiltration there's no rook
c2 it's super important
yes and just take on h6 you just win a
pawn
and we're going to check as a threat now
d5 bishop f6 check everything
is a problem for that black king oh nice
now d5
beautiful and just go work age seven
perhaps
yeah this is a good move as well and
what's the count how many pawns is white
up
bishop d4 three pawns yeah oh yeah this
is great he's simplifying as well f7 is
hanging
i think lawrence has got this game three
seconds ticking down
he's definitely got it and just d takes
c
how many pass pawns does a player need
and you can't even protect f7 rookie
seven check is coming and he wins on
time
wow and we this is how the entire match
started
robert it was like oh wow roberto's
coming in with 27
50 blitz lawrence is the underdog boom
he absolutely crushed him game one
same thing in the bullet talking about
28 50 bullet
lawrence comes in and says hey it's not
about raiding it's all about the board
baby
and and he comes in with a emphatic
start to this bullet portion
yeah and right now it's only a one point
deficit and this is the type of position
that lawrence
likes trying to get active here but i
like roberto's decision to go knight f3
to d2 trade off that menacing knight in
the center
now look at this it went from
potentially tactical to a positional
battle because
it's not opening up yet and i'm not a
fan of knight on g6
f4 looks like a great move because it's
going to be followed up by exactly that
e4 knight takes e4 and already roberto
is dictating the pace
he is and the queen on e8 is not happy
to see the e-file open up the rook on e1
will win that battle and knight g5 comes
to mind here
yep just trying to open up more of the
board the d6 pawn is hanging so knight
takes d6 can be played
fs5 also looked quite tempting there but
hey knight d6
you know free pawn open bishops this is
just commanding for roberto
all right so let's see how can black get
back into this thing that's what you
have to come up with if you're lawrence
you're down on the clock in addition to
being down a pawn so what can you do if
the light square bishops get traded
maybe then you feel like you have some
hope i like the move h5
it's just me too creating vague threats
of a kingside attack and now he goes on
the other side of the board
that's just honestly it's disorienting
rook d3 hit the g3 pawn
just uh get get involved in the position
somehow rook e3
is sort of covering that third rank
because of that i'd like to remove her
to d3 that was probably better
and if this knight could just go to f5
black suddenly has a ton of compensation
but now the knight came before get there
can i take on f4 just go bishop e5
and win my knight or something or queen
g5 yeah or even if i don't win the night
basically if i get you to play g5 i feel
like someone's getting mated and it's
not me
yeah and now queen g5 is a good move
because if you take on f4 with the
knight
bishop e5 happens cutting off your
discover check winning the knight on f4
yep and i was gonna say i like b6 just
to force lawrence to say look
are you committing to that diagonal with
queen b8 or not
and i actually don't feel like this is
so overwhelming
for white i mean it should lead to an
attack oh that's brookie
rookie what okay there's rookie two so
you somehow protect the rook there and
i'm even looking at moves like
rook to d5 there just doesn't work as
the bishop will take around the pawn but
wow rookie has to be played okay it was
rook
d but now he's getting out of this
yeah and he's got no time i would be
moving the black king
uh by the way to like h7 or something
just like out of the way that seems like
a reasonable play
and it said rook to b3 so he keeps
moving i like this move
f6 that looks like that's strong well if
you move the rook though rook be one
check king f2 queen g3 mate
so just don't lock your king up to f2
but actually the queen coming together
rick g5 that's one should lead to me
okay he had to go rookie one check first
i think
so both players seconds yeah making
mistakes in time troll yeah
this is playable oh it's very playable
he doesn't have time guys his position's
okay
watch out for bishop takes c6 as a
sacrifice if the rooks get traded brooke
takes g2
g2 oh my goodness
and now that's never k7 is happening
with bishop c6
yes and okay eight first good touch
seven rookie one check for k2 something
like that like just pin that bishop
yeah oh the king's coming to g3 oh my
gosh is gonna be a checkmate here
king king james three bishop bishop c4
yeah bishop c4 key one the king's
running away though
oh my goodness what the hell is going on
here i don't know
i don't know f7 this looks like it
should be enough for white
you're up a piece now the b7 pawn well
zombie seven yeah
wow what a great game lawrence is
is saying look i am here to play because
he was absolutely in that match after
looking
out of it for the entire opening that
was that was beautiful uh
play by lawrence to come back in that
game roberto just made the better
decisions
you know towards the end of that match
but uh what a game robert
and we have this opening that we saw in
game one and then we saw
again later in the match and lawrence
has fixed it he did not allow black to
play e5 and said he put e5 himself
white is down to pawn but look at these
pieces your minor pieces are dominating
you can castle play knight g5
pawn h3 to trap that knight oh knight h4
what a move taking with the f5 squad
trying to sacrifice some g6
take that uh for sure yep
and well besides it's funny i was
looking at the king side and it goes
right these are like oh okay that's a
freak
hanging as well yeah and now white must
be thrilled because you've regained the
material
and the king stuck in the center bishop
g5 as you said
excellent move where does that king go
nowhere
bishop f8 sad movie play yeah sad but
maybe necessary
and how do i end this game there's no
queen d3 trying to just take this pawn
at five if e6 there might be like a
knight
move to b5 or something like three four
knight e4
or the queen's protected actually be
careful but
knight b5 you can't take the knight
because queen takes b5 is made so knight
b5 going knight c7 check
could actually just pick up a bunch of
material
oh my goodness what a move love it
though queen takes f5 and just how do
you defend
you can't f7 is falling and very
importantly the bishop on g5 covers the
c1 square so if there's ever
any kind of queen c1 check you just
steal the queen
this is a nasty game lawrence is gonna
strike back right away it looks like
yeah he's in fine form and i see teddy
coleman in the chat
and he says does rook takes f5 work so
he was seeing the tactic that we
weren't quite focused on but look at
this play by lawrence trent
rook back to f1 is probably sufficient
here whoa
queen g6 he's just going to take
everything but where is the mate this is
how
winning positions can go wrong wait he
needed to take on e6 i think there
queen takes e6 to start he probably did
but knight no knight c5 check as bad as
queen 65
queen 65 what a blunder he's the whole
game he's gone now
and lawrence is in pain he just grimaced
there
and wait what wait what just wait sorry
what yeah how did that just happen
wasn't the d4
the d4 point was hanging with check and
me right
sorry what just happened there c4
wait now white's winning wait wait
that's an outside passport
i'm very confused g4 and then just bring
your king up and then play bishop e3 to
trade bishops at some point
yeah king e4 bishop e3 although actually
if you trade bishops there could be a
place where you can't get your king in
you need to be a bit careful about
that so just king can you bring his king
to the queen side
i'm confused yeah this is the right plan
i think this is the good plan
black's gonna have to you know get his
bishop to attack the e pawn or something
right but c5 falls and that's the second
pawn and now it's winning at that
moment what in the world did we just see
bishop e3 and i would play a4 nice move
yeah this is not easy even literally
what was that
how do you play queen c5 but not notice
the
so strange wow i wonder if he was just
happy to regain some material so he's
like okay
like i'm not dead lost anymore and then
he just didn't find the next follow-up
which
actually led to a forcing checkmate oh
my goodness
so run the pawn to a6 i guess you may as
well
don't know about g7 but okay it's all
all winning
well the a pawn is the wrong pawn so if
somehow the
king can win the g7 pawn you can run
back the other way but it's
no it's not nearly anything he's got it
you didn't have to bring that bishop
back but i think he sees
oh yeah that's sick
that's sick and nice touch there
and if you're roberto do you just spend
the next 10 seconds you waste the match
clock he says no
i don't think he feels comfortable right
now i was going to say the same thing i
i think
as roberto as the higher rated player
you want as many both games
right now in the match as close as you
can get there's 13 minutes left
but lawrence is leading the bullet he
entered down two games now he's only
down one
and it has been such a nerve-wracking
state of games where both players have
winning chances
may blunder then they're getting down to
the limit of their time but i think
lawrence has played better honestly in
the bullet thus far
yep i agree i agree just overall even
the games that go really bad
for him he had that one game i just
think that it's impressive he's able to
stay in and still generate winning
chances at some point
generally if you play a bullet game and
you have no winning chances ever
start to finish your opponent has played
just a master class
because it's bullet chess after all
things are going pretty fast completely
agreed and if we see this opening and
how this is gone
at first doesn't say hey i like what
lauren's doing trying to play for f5 but
then he made the move
bishop f6 was that a mouse slip uh
i don't know i feel like he he wants to
put that bishop on g7 but that's only
after seeing bishop f6 when the bishop's
on e7 i wouldn't have ever suggested
that
yeah so oh look at that move great
exchange sacrifice this is
classy everybody if you take the rook on
c6 the pawn takes back
the knight was actually trapped and even
if the knight were not trapped
is still a worthy sacrifice and now the
rook on c6 that's so powerful
yeah and that's just bullet chest for
you you want to look for those nasty
moves where
you know your opponent just can't see
the good way to play um it's all about
having a plan a bullet
and lawrence doesn't have a plan he
wanted to go for f5 he didn't do so and
now f5 is off the table
because your king gets through he has to
trade right or
b5 maybe okay b5 is clever and now the
queen
drops back and now you're more willing
to trade because the pawn on c6
followed by pawn and b5 that would be a
protected pass pawn
now if you take back with the pawn on c6
that could become a target later in the
game
lawrence is playing a bit better that b5
move was key and i think he's starting
to maybe
become optimistic about his position he
does in fact take now d
takes c6 the d6 pawn is weak and the
knight is free to go to a5 but how does
black
really fend the position because knight
a5 doesn't really make a threat and hey
you know what lawrence just have to
knight f4 queen h3
stuff here it comes and i thought queen
b7 was going to be
roberto's move just to trade queens
before playing c7 instead he pushed the
pawn which objectively should be good
as long as he doesn't get checkmated and
so queen takes a like
yes that's a great point queen takes
eight just wins right now
although yeah yeah that's the chances
you need
that's why he played f3 and that's a
great move the rook on c2 is also a nice
defender so now queen takes a8
he wants queen a7 check by the way
that's why he did this but
um maybe knight c5 after that i don't
know lawrence is very tricky with that
move a5 you think he does nothing
six seconds he needs to move quickly
queen a seventh check yeah can you have
one queen e3 you get scared
the next queen e3 oh no oh that's big
queen e3
the knights hanging on age three but
that's a movie
yeah resign lawrence you have to resign
get a new game
resign resign yep new game that's okay
even in these games he has his chances
and it seems like with the white pieces
lawrence has been way more confident
he has him but now he changed his
opening back to some main lines
and i don't like this because it's very
solid for black
it may be slightly better for white and
know the two bishops all that good stuff
but look at this the queens are oh this
is good for black
if you win this game it's going to take
you several minutes
and 100 moves several minutes 100 moves
great technique
i mean just everything and lauren's
off to a good start though he has the
pawn to c4 d4 right now he plays g4
trying to use the bishops
but this is the problem when you claim i
have a two bishops revenge
is your light square bishop actually
that strong the answer is no
because all of black's pawns are on
light squares that can be good if you
can attack the pawns
but how are you going to attack f7 you
can so look at this position i think
it's
very pleasant for black even better
bishop f6
this is so so brutal when you got that
two-game deficit
and you're just looking at the position
you're just not happy with what you see
now bishop f6 after rook h1 and you're
even just worse
you're winning all the pawns terrible oh
no
and and the worst part about this is you
can't make a draw anytime soon even if
you are able to save
the half point which may not be likely
at this point in time but it's going to
take forever
so you have to sit there and watch your
opponent
try to play for a win and knowing that
you have a very good chance of losing
this
after wasting like three more minutes
minimum
that's right and lawrence he can go rook
h.a rook
just start over the queen side attack
those pawns and maybe now
it's not that bad for him it looks hard
to press for
black but
actually how does black try to win here
um
maybe like rook h7 rick h3 with e4
that's i think the way to go right you
need to push your past pawns
and your extra pawn is in the center
so a5 is a consideration for lawrence
just to try to
break down black's queen-side pawn
structure but he can also put his work
on d5
right anyway he's gonna get a bunch of
checks lawrence isn't
defending this really well he is he is
in full credit
there's 45 seconds a piece the only
problem is there's so much shuffling
going on right now the time
is not going down here comes f4 and you
have to go back
right king e4 rook d4 checkmate that
would not have been fun
and the problem with playing f4 is now
e4 is harder to accomplish so you're not
creating the past pawn
but the good news is you kick that king
back as you mentioned and rook f8 check
just keep checking this king
brook back to e8 the worst part iman is
the 50 move
rule counter restarted when f4 was
played and now
it's going again but lawrence is doing
this perfectly this is a draw
yeah it is but i think roberto is also
doing this perfectly
from the perspective of the match right
and oh now you're dropping the c5 pawn
can't take c5 and then you just keep the
king cut off but you're
gonna play so many more moves here so
many more moves
rook c4 to d4 get your king back
involved or this
yeah and white just needs to keep the
king cut off
look at that like it you might not
notice it guys but that match clock it
was like at 10 minutes
when this game started or more this is
really really bad news
for lawrence and you need to be able to
start
the last game so right now down two
points let's say lawrence wins a game
with
10 seconds left that's still good he
still gets that final game so
you're very much keeping on the match
clock in here lawrence is holding the
draw
he's playing this very well but it's
getting lower and lower on the clock
where he can't afford any more draws
after robredo can play
until the match clock's at like two
minutes um literally this could last
four more minutes
oh and here comes the king watch out
okay rook a3 was
okay or this is yeah then you can go
rook a3 after king e3
lawrence he's doing a great job
yeah this is just a bunch of random
moves essentially hoping that lawrence
goes wrong
and for lawrence he's just like this is
painful but i am
digging deep and i'm holding this game
rook d5 now rook d5 there we go that's
that's actually
the first mistake from roberto molina
and now
now this is a lot easier in fact he's
going to collect most of these puns
oh man the black can keep playing this
after this
that's crazy maybe it was smart to lose
that pawn
oh now he's going to lose the f pawn and
lawrence is going to play it
oh my god it's still going to be a draw
oh god
that was a mouse lit but no that's a
great move what a move rook g4
by the way why didn't lawrence take that
is he trolling take that make your draw
yeah maybe he's trying to win now but
that's ridiculous yeah he should have
taken
he's shooting himself in the foot dude
take the rock what are you doing okay
he just wasted his own time there wow
rook g4 though that was
excellent yeah that's just like one of
those moves that
isn't necessary to play but it's cool
when you see it that is 100
the best move in the position and to see
it in time trouble in a bullet scramble
when this match is on the line that was
well done by roberto because
all of a sudden lawrence won one pawn
and was about to win the second and then
he really could have tried to play for a
win
but roberto he is too smooth there he
finds a way out
queen f3 the d4 pawn can i capture that
at some point soon
talk about smooth i mean look at these
games that he's get what lawrence
where's the conviction we need
we need uh like f5 in that position we
need e5 i don't know we need c5 we need
moves because look the clock is ticking
down it's four minutes and this is just
a boring
everything defends everything position
yeah f5 was a really good move there
probably would have won black a pawn
but maybe lawrence just saw what roberto
did he said hey you know piling up on
the d file and trying to uh
outplay my opponent end game sounds
about right but now d6
this is just not good by by lawrence
queen d2
take trade a pair rogues pawn on d5 this
move is fine as well like it's just
this is the wrong wrong stuff i think
and nice move of rook d6 if you took on
d5
queen takes d8 was possible and two
rooks for the queen so instead we have
this position where it's a
solid position for black white can't
really move because you don't want to
drop the d5 pawn
and look at lawrence go though he's
bringing the c-pawn up the board i think
he has some chances here
as he activates all of his pieces i i
think that
this is a really bad position to be in
for lawrence
this looks like a like a rook d5 hello
what's going on here it takes to take
some b5 yeah there's a queen eight check
right at the end just to win the b5 pawn
yeah yeah he but this this is just gonna
go forever
it's so so unfortunate king somewhere he
should have played c4
instead of taking on d5 he actually had
chances to outplay
roberto and i'm looking at the match
clock two minutes and almost 50 seconds
now
he as soon as he finishes this game he
and his wife to draw
he will need to win the one the next one
very quickly because he may run out of
time
it just won't be possible i this is a
bad sign
um the reason he took that is he wants
to make the draw quicker and if you
trade the queens you can do that
however someone can absolutely still win
this game
right and that someone looks more likely
to be roberto whose king
is far more active let's say you play f3
play g4 and
there are some tricks here yeah he's
going for g he's going to play a3
g4 or what i think so at least well the
a3 move i'm a little
nervous to play because it brings it
closer to the enemy king but this
okay f5 okay this is oh it's getting
closer
if you play a3 and then a5 a4 then white
wind so a3
a6 and a4 a5 wow but now
f4 check now you can play 50 moves yes
if you're
if you're a bird don't play 50 moves
it's over the match definitely
definitely oh man you want to tilt
lawrence trent this is the way to do it
he's played 49 moves and then let your
minute expire
in the game the match is over for sure
right and honestly at this point it
already looks over because a minute
this is a master class on how to send
lawrence trent into orbit
[Laughter]
yes because the pawns take away all of
the squares from the enemy king
and roberto did the right thing playing
out 50 moves and he could have wasted
all of the time yeah he could have just
sat there at the end
right there at the end you know now that
the match
is his for the taking he could score a
couple extra bucks if he wins the final
game
because the thing is if you're gonna be
the guy who
plays those king moves and no judgment
for me at all on that but if you're
gonna be that guy
why not also just waste the extra minute
at the end i mean there's there's no
reason you don't just end the match
right there
and it is the right match strategy to
play that out it would have been
it's it may seem improper or whatever
because they can agree on a draw but it
would have been bad for roberto's
chances because let's say they drew that
game quickly
and then lawrence wins and he's time for
one more game you're doing a disservice
to yourself
by the way this position is just
completely dominating for black
yeah unfortunately like this pawn is
goner and it's just all gonna be
uh queen side play but lawrence uh
is not giving it his all because he
knows that
the match clock is going to expire i
think i think he's very conscious of
that
and like i said roberto couple extra
dollars because the
winner gets half of the prize fund for
winning the match and then the other
half is split by win percentage so a
final victory uh gives him a little more
money and
for lawrence you know he's gonna be just
gutted after this and we'll have both
players on for an interview
of course like we always do but lawrence
you know he was up two games
at two different points and he was
storming back in the bullet but
it wasn't enough and roberto just too
powerful
yeah there comes the apon basically you
had to stop
uh the pawn from getting to a2 this is
over
yeah and he even stops for b3 and okay
the match is over
both players know it and lawrence knows
that he had
every chance in this match robert to to
make a combat to win this thing
in every format he was impressive he
started out the five minute ahead wait a
minute he started out the five minute
the three minute and the one minute
with with a lead it's pretty impressive
and you know well he got to the one
minute then he was he lost the threat in
the
late stage of the three minute and
that's when roberto had the lead but we
met like he was ahead in each format so
like he started five minutes and in the
five-minute games
he he started out with the lead in the
three-minute games he started out two
and a half to half
right and in the bullet he started out
with the win so it's kind of like he had
the hammer so to speak
to start things off for sure for sure he
came out
in a winning streak that's absolutely
the case and we'll be right back because
we're going to bring both the players in
for a post-match interview
will be very interesting to hear their
thoughts and especially from
the emotional lawrence trent but he gave
it his all he did
and welcome back everybody we are uh
lucky to be joined by the players here
for a post game interview that's
roberto molina and lawrence trent are
here with us
and first of all of course uh congrats
to roberto for coming away with the
match victory but i'm actually going to
go over to you lawrence the
the emotions from you we can see them on
the camera so i know that there's
probably a lot of thoughts going through
your head
can you just take us through the match
maybe in your eyes because we we were
just witnessing you on camera
going all over the place reacting to
some of those blunders
uh flags unfortunate situations that
happen how do you feel
yeah basically if i didn't blunder a
piece every game i played i might be a
good chess player you know
um i'll be honest i felt like i played
in general pretty
pretty darn good chess i just blundered
all the time i lost on time in positions
i shouldn't have lost roberto was
extremely fast
he put me under pressure i don't feel
like roberto completely outplayed me
though from start to finish i just was
hanging pieces
and that game where i was the pawn up
with the pawn on e4 and losing that
was just uh shocking um
i was actually really happy with the way
i played in general
uh by the just ridiculous blunders and
if i cut those out i win the match by a
by a long margin but credit to roberto
you know
he uh he's stuck in there even when he
was uh
he was worse and uh even when he was
behind
and then there was that stretch where he
won four in a row that really took it
out of me
we went into the bullet where he had a
two-point advantage and
uh you know i tried i i tried but
he was just too quick he was just a
little too sharp in the bullet
and i just couldn't get the uh couldn't
get the
margin closer so you know congrats to
roberto but i do feel like
like i've lost a lot of matches before
but i'm i don't feel too bad with this
one because
there were just so many stupid i mean
literally the most ridiculous hanging
pieces hanging rooks getting flagged
how many points did i just burn uh
those you know i don't i feel like there
are only
a handful of games where roberto truly
outplayed me
without me blundering a piece that's my
interpretation maybe he's
feeling something different well roberto
on your end you know first of all
congratulations you played it
both you played an excellent match and i
want to ask you because
early on the games were very tactical
but then there were some games where you
just said no tactics for you i'm going
to squeeze the second game of the match
for example
and others as well was that part of your
strategy
to avoid tactics and to play more
strategic battles
yeah first of all thanks or
the opportunity to play again and
yeah general i
am a positional player and i prefer for
example
change queens played in the game
but in the beginning of the match uh
i can't i can't do that
and he made me the two
first games and the preparation of
opening
his total disaster in the beginning of
the match
but i put my red in the right place
and try to try to fix this problem
for example change some
moves or the in the open
right yeah it seemed like maybe you
adjusted
some of the openings that lawrence was
playing he was able to get like really
good attacks especially in the early
portion
um would you say that uh roberto in the
uh and the bullet was that of a format
that you were expecting
to be able to do better than lawrence in
like you were
trying to keep the match close in blitz
and then wait for the bullet portion to
score some points
um i think i just play
one game after one and the game and
i i don't uh have a plan to
for example win the matching bullets i
just
play one game and add order and another
justice
yeah i mean my match plan obviously i
looked at roberto's games he is a very
positional player
he likes drier positions so it was
absolutely clear to me that i had to
take him
uh you know into a dogfight and get
things messy from the off and
i was actually really happy with uh with
the openings i chose and
i i think if you remember my match
against danny where he didn't adjust
roberto adjusted immediately and that
made a huge difference for phil
um he adjusted from game three he didn't
give me too many chances i had to work a
lot and there were a lot of these dry
positions where i just made
classic mistakes i mean blundering the
rook on d4 to allow rook a8
allowing the pawn on hc all of this
stuff in blitz which you shouldn't allow
i allowed
and you know ultimately it was the
blunders that cost me
although i think the the actual match
was was super close and if i'd avoided
those i think i
think i would have won but that's that's
the way it goes it's blitz
um at least at least it was extremely
competitive
and i think the audience would have had
a great time watching these games
because there was
i can't wait to look at these games back
because there are a lot of fireworks
everywhere even my first game i wanted
to throw my mouse out the window because
i went king g3 and i wanted to go knight
g3 obviously it was just a mouse tip
obviously i'm not going king g3
394 but anyway i mean there were certain
super fun games the one where i had the
queen on h g for all of this so
i enjoyed myself you know and credit to
roberto
as i say startling guy uh tough guy to
to beat over a long stretch three hours
is a long time
it's very intense and uh i wish him all
the best for the for the rest of the
competition
thanks
they change the mind in the for example
the karaoke defense
this opening is my main
uh main weapon and you crushed
me in the first game i i think what it
was
what can i do now
it's amazing i do more preparation for
these matches than when i played for my
gm norms that's not even an
exaggeration but
uh yeah super fun games a mix of
everything so
uh yeah i'll go away with uh my head
held high
lawrence quick question about that
actually because we were very impressed
with both your play it was a
pretty hard fought match and never felt
like any side was
running away with it but you mentioned
gm norms you very publicly
tweeted about how you know now is the
time i'm going to
really dig deep and try to make that
grand master title yeah what has your
work been like how have you been
preparing because the preparation for
this match looked good what's your
overarching plan looking like well i
mean this i mean just playing matches
like this really gives you the taste to
want to go for it
so uh basically what i'm doing is i'm
waiting it out just a little longer
until covid
uh is is a bit more clear obviously
traveling around is still
a little bit tricky um so it's really
i'm looking towards the summer
i'm going to be getting uh getting a
very famous coach to help me i've
already reached out to him he's already
agreed
um and it's time to go for it because i
think you know
if i cut out the silly mistakes you know
i can see it myself i can really play
with these guys robert so he's
27 50 20 under 2850 blitz player i mean
he's he's a super strong blitz player
super strong player in general and yeah
as i say
um it's going to be a lot of adjustments
to get this gm title because
i've got a lot of points to make hundred
points uh gotta get a norm
uh and it basically means effectively
dropping everything else
uh doing doing a little things on the
side but for the most part just full
full steam ahead and i really want it
now i'm in in the right place in my life
where i can do it
i've got the flexibility to do it so i'm
just gonna do it
uh just gotta grab the bull by the horns
amman did it a few years ago i remember
sweating amman
you know playing in all these swisses
and isle of man and
everything else i saw him everywhere
grinding it's gonna take a
crazy amount of volume to get it as well
i'm probably gonna have to play 200
games
at least to even have a chance um
you know but hard work uh and and
finding the love for the game it's about
that love and
and even today i really loved it i
really enjoyed
playing some of those games so that's
what it's going to need and
hopefully fingers crossed look if you're
out there and you're a naysayer
you're a debbie downer you're a you're a
you're you know you're a non-believer
you know where i'm at at lawrence trent
i am on twitter hit me up
lines ready professional i've got a
professional handicapper who's doing the
lines he's done all the spreadsheets
it's all ready
i will i will back myself if you don't
think i can do it
come and hit me up because i've got a
surprise for you my friend
i'm going to take that money and i'm
going to say i told you so
that's it i like that attitude for sure
and roberto on your side
uh you're clearly a very strong player i
believe you have a couple norms
what are your aspirations like are you
trying to become a grandmaster as well
yeah of course i have two gm norms and
i i just be studying streaming
uh some class and focus to improve my
chest
but the problem here in brazil
don't have tournaments
i don't don't know when i will play
again for
gm norms i think i need to travel
to europe i don't know
but i am studying foreign proof
to improve my chest just this in the
screen
just sounds like a good plan i guess we
we obviously wish you both the best and
hope that we can never
invite either of you to this tournament
ever again um
i am not a gm tournament but you are
gonna be continuing uh roberto in this
event
so you're moving on to the next round
you're the first player uh to win their
second round match up and you'll be
playing
either lars oscar hauck or teddy coleman
in the next
round have you seen either of their
previous matches or do you know about
anything uh anything about them as
players yeah
i saw the the games uh just a little bit
of course but uh now uh i need to spread
it
for example the openings and the style
of playing the positions
and just wait for the
next opponent right
yep it's a good way to do things take it
one match at a time as you said
uh i echo uh robert's comments earlier
about how
the match was honestly one of the
highest level matches we've seen
every match has blunders but seriously
this match was back and forth and it
never felt like it was clear
until literally the last game of the
match so
a big congrats to both of you lawrence
sounds like he had a great competitive
time even uh taking the loss there so
best of luck on the gm quest for both
you and and thanks for taking the time
to play and share your thoughts congrats
again
to you roberto thanks very much
all right and we've heard from the
players there's a really nice one to
take
take their time and robert nice to see
you
nice to see uh lawrence just have so
much to say complimentary to his
opponent as well as indicating hey if i
can play chess like this i'm i'm ready
for the gm title yeah no the level of
play was
super high in this one it's almost
unfortunate that this was the match up
in a sense for both players because they
could have been eliminated
and it's not that they're any easy
matchups but just something about the
stylistic
imbalance here gave both players chances
we saw them thrive in
their respective elements and roberto
when all was said and done
it did seem like he just barely eat this
one out and he was a deserved champion
so i
it wouldn't be surprised no matter who
won this match and now that roberto has
one you ask him
what does he think about the remaining
competition after what we saw today
against a determined lawrence trent
yeah i'm not going to call him the
favorite but i don't see why anyone
would be favored over him either
yeah that's a that's a great point as uh
he
moves on in the bracket and uh we'll see
who he's up against there's
lots more of these matches coming up
we've already highlighted and previewed
some of them but
what an exciting match today i think
coming into this match you called it and
you were pretty much spot on that this
was one of the hardest ones to guess
who was going to be the winner because
we know that lawrence can come in
and not be playing his best and maybe
it's a white watch but when lawrence is
focused and he was today
he said he does more prep for this than
his gm norm tournament
uh and i love to see lawrence when he's
that motivated playing that type of
chess so
i thought that lawrence is showing in
this entire tournament his match against
danny as well as this one is something
to be proud of
absolutely and for roberto you know in
the post-match interview
essentially he was just very casual
about it you know i'm studying
i'm getting ready i'm always working on
my chest i'm streaming now which is
great to hear
and i hope that he continues his success
because that level of play that we saw
today i know it sounds like we've
mentioned it many times but it's just
true
i was really impressed by how sharp both
players were
early in the game or in the match i
should say roberto was finding these
pins
out of nowhere and just being tactically
alert and lawrence was
drumming a play out of nowhere coming up
with blistering attacks with that
one game with queen d7 knight f4 queen
h3
where roberto ended up losing on time so
both players showed their strengths
i think that blunders as you mentioned
many times they happen right we expect
that to happen
but i was like really thrilled to see
both players compete
so fiercely yep and this was uh
you know that that'll be it for us
wrapping uh things up here i guess the
match finished 12 to nine
uh overall so uh roberto molina is gonna
move on to the next round
and uh when those matches happen you
know either
robert and myself or another commentary
team will be here to
guide you through the the tricky
calculations and bring you all the
action but
robert it was a pleasure pleasure as
always today uh this was
probably one of the most exciting
matches chess wise that i've had the
pleasure to commentate
yeah and there's i can't think of anyone
else i'd rather jump back in my chair
alongside
when some of these shocking things
happen but i'm on seriously it was a
great time the players
treated us so it made our lives easy and
thanks of course to all the fans who
continue to tune in watch these players
root them on
we can feel your energy so we really
appreciate that
yep well take care guys um there's going
to be
lots more of these matches coming up so
make sure to
stay tuned in and of course there's all
those
regular chess.com events that are coming
up as well as the regular ones on the
calendar title tuesday arena kings so
just so much chess happening guys stay
tuned and uh
that's all for us for now take care guys
and we'll see you next time
you